right so next slide this slide talks
about just
all the populations really that have a
connection here to the hospital so
although new hampshire hospital serves a
finite number of individuals
the impact that we have on towns
communities businesses and health
systems
so i have a question back on that slide
too sorry
that's okay i hope i hope miss rounds
warned you i tend to do this but
okay so as your circle uh is outside
there
i don't i don't i'm not actually seeing
emergency rooms
and the reason that is relevant as you
know historically
we i think there's a better word than
warehousing
but for a few years we were warehousing
uh
people that needed inpatient care at the
new hampshire hospital
in ers and we were using up a whole lot
of their
uh capacity sometimes a third of their
emergency room capacity
so so it seems to me like that's one of
our key populations that we serve
are the state's emergency rooms and i'm
just curious
how we're doing these days on allowing
the flow of patients from ers into
new hampshire hospital or is there a
slide on that or is this the right slide
to talk about that
that there is more detail later i i
would agree with you that you know under
the
that circle of hospitals um more
specifically
a direct impact is on the emergency
department
and yes we we have more detail later in
the presentation about referrals
about waitlist and and the issue of
boarding
so this slide just talks about what the
scope of service is here at new
hampshire hospital and what we do
and what we don't do at this point we've
talked a lot about
what what the hospital does but we want
to be clear about what we don't do
so new hampshire hospital does not
provide substance use treatment unless
it's secondary to a serious mental
illness so for a patient to be here at
new hampshire hospital
substance use disorder cannot be the
primary
diagnosis we do
not have our own in-house diagnostic
services such as pathology or radiology
and we don't provide any outpatient
service to the community
the slide just shows our our team our
our new hampshire hospital
state employee team just to give you
some context on on
you know who's working here at the
hospital and also their years of service
i think what's great about
the team is that we really have
representation
um among definitely different skill sets
some of our leaders have been here for
you know well you can see rosie costanzo
our chief nursing officer 33 years
cindy pomonas 20 years beth nagi 22
and then um there are folks like myself
joe christie ellen lapointe
who are newer to state service but have
worked in the private sector
and and bring that skill set so i think
it's a great combination
so moving on to key performance
indicators
over the past few years the hospitals
made a concerted effort to design our
strategic plan around the needs of
citizens across new hampshire
we've come to find that these needs
translate into five objectives for our
organization
delivering high quality care creating
timely access to care
maintaining fiscal stewardship providing
an exceptional patient experience
and improving employee well-being
from those objectives we have numerous
metrics but in being 100
transparent the hospital's collective
effort primarily focuses
on just one of these strategic
imperatives and that's creating timely
access
to care or reducing the emergency room
boarding
which i think was what you were
this slide refers to referrals over time
through the years and you can see that
it's remained relatively flat
but although referrals remain relatively
flat the wait list
continues to grow particularly over the
past year
likewise as the waitlist grows the
problem of emergency room boarding grows
there a separate slide on the
to summarize the boarding problem is it
is
is this it this is part of it yep we'll
get into children as well
in more detail so
just to make sure i'm reading this right
in 2012 we
we hit 1913
uh adult patients who were
in emergency rooms that had been
identified as needing
admission to the new career hospital
that's by days so that represents the
patient but also the number of days that
they were waiting
one guy for a week that would be seven
of that
1913. you got it yep
representative walter has a question i
think you just answered i
i didn't realize that was days and i
wanted to know what the
average what the average number of
people
in um emergency rooms
by day was i might have that on another
slide
if it's okay i'll keep going and if i
don't
i'm sorry i still find your
representative are you
do you have a follow-up would you like
to keep talking that's okay
yeah no i just have one more question i
want she may have the
information just what is the average
stay in the emergency room do you have
that how long do people wait in the
emergency room
we can get that for you i know we have
that
i'm just making a note i'll get that
that would be actually kind of a cool
thing to do with this slide is to use
the right
side of it as the average uh length of
uh
boarding you know so that we could see
it overall but
i i'm a little disappointed in this
slide because i had heard
anecdotally that we had solved this
problem in the last
budget and i don't consider 1400
patient days to be solved what's it
going to take
to bend this curve down in an aggressive
appropriate manner
thank you for the question i i think
this is a great slide because it does
show the progress that we made between
uh 2017 right up um
to 2020 and you see that
significant dip in march of 2020
so over time we were and and we'll get
the information about the average
number of days waiting but i can tell
you that that had been trending down
significantly
over these period of years since 2017.
what you see on this slide is during the
period of time between 2019 and 2020 we
developed the contract with hampstead
hospital
we started transitioning
children services to them beginning in
january
and then we escalated that in march due
to the pandemic
we had been having kids admitted there
by attrition
but because of the emergency really
within the pandemic in march
we um aggressively approached that and
worked with hampstead to transfer kids
over
so there was a period of days in march
where we had no wait list
we opened up adult beds we increased
access
and then you see the number going up
again
over the summer and that really is
representative of you know once we
filled those beds
having an issue with discharge following
that
um especially for elders because
you know i think as you know during the
pandemic many if not all of the nursing
homes were closed to admissions
at certain points of time including
glencliff
so there was the elders that we had
difficulty with discharging
but it was also during that period of
time
that community resources were limited uh
due to the pandemic as well
so i think really you you know you can
see the
you know the the dip in the number again
of increasing number of beds but this
climb represents the back
and we're disappointed too it was you
know one of my happiest days
um that day in march where we had um no
one
and it just has crept up since then i
appreciate
that you're a mid-section of the
pipeline that you have
input issues into the pipeline and you
have output issues with that pipeline to
get people
into back into the communities so um
so this is not an easy problem this is
an entire statewide systemic
problem um and i just i just hope
the smart people are continuing to look
at this to figure out
how how we're going to free up our
emergency rooms emergency
rooms have a purpose and it's not to
take care of boarding the those with
mental health
issues so thank you and
i think what's most important for your
committee to know
is that you know with everything else
that we do at the hospital
this is our number one priority this is
it this is what we work
on every single day trying to increase
access
thank you i don't see any other
questions you can continue
okay um so
this next slide talks about new
hampshire hospital census trends over
time
i think this also is a great slide
because it shows our efforts
in increasing just access
for patients in the ed so all of this
growth in emergency room boarding is
despite the hospital's effort
to increase our capacity the hospital
did have an interruption in capacity due
to kova 19 quarantining protocols
but we've since then brought capacity
back up to 100
and we're operating with a census of 172
to 175 patients
on any given day so looking back in july
of 2019 you can see
average census was around 154 so we've
really increased
um increased bed numbers
by 20 essentially and that directly
correlates with the hampstead contract
the dip that you see here in the fall
that was when we had our first
cases a patient cases here at the
hospital
of coven 19 and then we had to implement
some
quarantine and isolation procedures so
although 163 is the last number that's
shown here on the slide
we're at 175 today and pretty much every
day
if we have a fluctuation of one or two
it's really just due to patients being
maybe
um evaluated in the emergency room for a
medical issue
but other than that we are maintaining
all the time so do you have
um a supply of vaccine a covet vaccine
that you can use on your patients
regardless
of their other comorbidities and age so
that you're dealing with a vaccinated
inpatient population thank you for that
question we
have been able to access vaccine for our
patients that
meet the requirement under 1b um
so we have not yet gotten uh vaccine to
vaccinate 100
of our patients but we have received it
for those that qualify under 1b so in
particular our elders
so anyone over 65 on our elder care unit
but we do also have a number of patients
um just by the nature of their severe
mental illness who also have
a number of other medical conditions so
we started vaccinating patients
two weeks ago and we continue receiving
vaccine
and and administering those in weekly
clinics on our units
okay not being a clinician i would just
think that it would
be beneficial if you could just 100
vaccinate
new uh new admissions just
because this is probably a more physical
group
of patients than other hospitals have
and
that close interaction it would be nice
just to get that extra layer of
protection for your
employees i agree 100
and i think that as more vaccine is
received here in the state i anticipate
that we'll get there um and and
you're so right you know for our
patients in particular our our patients
that may be
you know struggling with homelessness um
they're really at risk
um so definitely whatever vaccine we can
get
we will administer all right
okay representative wallner has a
question there yes
um thank you so
recently i thought i had understood
that ten of the adult beds at new
hampshire hospital
had been converted once again to
beds for children so
i'm wondering if one if that is if that
is correct
and if it is correct um
where did what did we what did we
provide for the 10
are those is that just 10 more adults
who now are in the emergency rooms
how is that working
so yes the way that that's working is we
are temporarily accepting children again
and we anticipate that it will be
short-term really
um into the spring around may
child weightless numbers had grown so
dramatically
that it was it was just not sustainable
the number of kids
at a certain point there were 50
children waiting in the ed
it was more than adults um so the the
quickest thing that we could do
um and it's not the long-term solution
by any means but the quickest thing we
could do
was um open up a kid unit again here at
the hospital
so um the day that we made that decision
we were again at 100 occupancy actually
we were over 100
i think our census was 177 um the day
that we decided to open up the
children's unit
we did have to temporarily stop adult
admissions during that time
needed to work through some discharges
and right now
we are our census is 165 adults
and 10 children we're accepting adult
admissions again
but you are correct you know 10 of those
beds are
offline for adults so we have seen a
slight increase
in adults waiting in the ed as we work
through this process
but um it is it is planned to be
temporary
um and in the meantime my understanding
is um that the department
uh works closely with other drfs and
hospitals
to ask them to to really take part in
increasing access to adults during this
time period so that we could try to
minimize
um any negative effects on the adult
thank you thank you you have a follow-up
your hands up still
i'm sorry no that's that answers my
question thank you
okay so i think what i heard in there
but just to make it explicit
is that you all have prioritized
getting kids out of the ers
more quickly than the adults and that
that's an active prioritization effort
it was um that is that is correct and
you'll see in future slides that what's
different about children during this
time period
is that although adult referrals had
been fairly
steady what we've seen during the
pandemic is that children's referrals
so i think this slide is a good summary
of the situation for adults in referrals
so again key takeaways adult referrals
have been steady
the waitlist has grown
not only new hampshire hospital but also
the drfs and hot in
in the other in private hospitals um
have been
impacted by covet 19. so um at the same
time during this pandemic that we have
had
periods of time where we had to initiate
quarantine
and reduce access the same thing has
been happening in hospitals
they've had some clusters of illness as
well so
at this point it doesn't seem like it's
made a significant impact on the wait
list
but the wait list has been growing
really steadily over time
so you see some spikes with those
quarantine time periods
but that's not really the primary reason
for the wait list i think
as you said chairman edwards this is
this is a
problem we've been struggling with for a
while
on any given day this is really
important the fifth bullet point
at least half of the patients at new
hampshire hospital could be better
served in a less restrictive environment
so so i don't want to start a long
conversation here i just want to do a
checkpoint with you
has has anyone ever taken a look
at a partnership between the sununu
youth center and the new hampshire
hospital i understand there's
a lot of facility space over sununu
that's uh that's basically uh mothballed
um
kind of a yes or no have people
investigated
the feasibility of using some of that
moth bald space it's the sununu center
my and i haven't personally done that in
investigation or research but my
understanding is that the department has
and that it was not found um realistic
um to utilize for um for inpatient care
that's my understanding could you give
me the bullet points of the summary
of that that feasibility look yeah
i don't get that not being formal but i
just would like to know the bullet
points
sure representative has a question
on bullet number five what
what alternative what kind of um
less restrictive environment have we
worked towards during this past couple
of years
i think there did we remove
some did we do some work at the
philbrook center
and move some people from new hampshire
hospital over to philbrook
and what other kinds of work have we
done
to provide some
less restrictive environments yes we did
we we opened up a transitional housing
program over at philbrook
that's 16 beds so that was a project
that we worked on through the summer
and we opened that in september um and
that program and you'll we'll we'll get
into detail of the program and another
slide deck but
that's been very successful in helping
us transition patients out of the
hospital
while they're looking for housing
another area
that we need more help with
is just supported
housing in the community along the lines
of what nfi does
so nfi provides a great deal of
structure and
you know in addition to the housing and
they have robust programming
they have an extensive wait list to get
into nfi so we struggle with the nfi
wait list
for elders people who may need assisted
living level of care
or a nursing home level of care that has
also been a significant challenge that
we've been working on
um you'll hear more about that with the
glencliff presentation but the other
thing that we've been doing
is um doing outreach to nursing homes to
see
if they would um you know become a
partner to us
um in in working with patients
considering patients
who have psychiatric illness that have
been stabilized at new hampshire
hospital
so that's ongoing work that's happening
um to try to
make a more robust system for for these
folks in the community
so those are the different pieces we've
been trying to target and you'll hear
more about that
um when um behavioral health does their
presentation
for you i think maybe this afternoon or
or tomorrow
there's they have a lot of programming
that they're working on as well
right yes one follow-up
in the bud the budget that we're looking
at the governor's proposed budget
is there funding in here for additional
um less restrictive
housing for for mental health
patients yes
yes there is and there are rfps that the
department is pursuing even now
thank you representative
thank you very much um this is just a
question we got the briefing book
from the department so thank you karen
um i was just wondering if um heather
wanted to call our attention to anything
that's in the briefing book
were there any pages i think that the
department starts on page 165 and i
didn't know if there were
any details in the briefing book that
you would like
us to be sure to notice thanks
i'm just going to ask him we're asking a
broader question representative nordgren
i want to check in with mr ripple on
this um
we we have prior to the briefing book
been of being available we've gone
through the slide deck and then we've
gone into the excel sheet
the briefing book adds another potential
source of
input how should we do that should we be
asking the presenters to hit the
briefing book
ideas as they go through the powerpoint
or
is that a separate conversation
uh it has been done that way in past
years they've gone through the
presentations and then
the briefing book and then the actual
accounts i'm not sure if they're
prepared to do that this time or not
though
i don't want to put miss milkween on the
spot here
uh are you up on what's in the briefing
book are you ready to talk about that
after you get through your slide deck
yes i i think that was our plan was to
go through the slide deck and then i'm
gonna
pass it over to um joe christie our cfo
to get into more
detail in the book if that's okay
let me check representative is that
acceptable to you
okay other questions keep going oh nfi
you have to be careful with the acronyms
nfi what is that
oh gosh you're putting me on the spot
nfi
i don't remember what that stands for
i'm sorry but they have a number of
contracted
centers where they provide the
transitional housing so there
is concord i think is the biggest
program um so the concord program but
there's also
a couple of other locations in the state
you helped me by making it so i don't
i will look it up though i should know
that
so sort of the segue here um into the
question around adults versus children
so
this slide shows the dramatic increase
they have steadily increased through the
summer and the fall
and what's important to know and it you
know it's here in the bullet but
it doesn't take a significant increase
in referrals to result in ed boarding
um you know the over time
and we sort of touched on it when we
were talking about days waiting versus
number of individuals it doesn't take
that much of an increase to really
high referral volumes in subsequent
months can cause
significant capacity restraints this is
further exacerbated in facilities that
are struggling to discharge during the
covet 19 pandemic
this this has come up in particular at
hampstead
with the discharge issue during the
pandemic so
um for children that are discharging
home
not a problem but for children who are
um in placement and residential
placement
in particular if they are
had an out-of-state placement planned or
was current
um there have been a lot of restrictions
around
kids moving around during the pandemic
so in particular
vermont and maine um have had some
pretty
you know serious you know restrictions
on on children crossing the border
so placement has been difficult even in
um in state residential placement has
been challenging during
um the pandemic and they've had some
significant restrictions as well
so this has led kids to be waiting
longer to discharge so again
back door issue for hampstead um it that
that's what this
is um for kids waiting for placement
so representative nordron has a question
thank you very much um i don't know
where to ask this question
um but we did fund mobile units
for psychiatry um in the last budget and
i
i don't know kevin maybe can tell us
if those are still in or where they went
or what department would they would be
i'm not sure where they ended up or what
happened
or if they even were used by the
department
thanks
i'm not sure if the funds were spent on
those
mobile crisis units or not um
i believe they would be in they would be
in either behavioral health or
children's behavioral health most likely
i'm not sure if they were budgeted
in the governor's budget or not but
that's something we can get to when we
get to those presentations
so this slide shows the the child wait
list
and again as referrals have increased so
has the wait list
and again as a result new hampshire
hospital is currently admitting children
here as well as adults we anticipate
but you can see i mean these really are
unprecedented
numbers of children waiting the other
thing i want to mention
um is really for for kids
this is really um the impact you know of
isolation the pandemic
different school systems you know it's
really incredible to look at and over
time we've had
um seasonality to referrals so um
you know here when we used to take care
of kids here and also at hampstead
typically during the summer summer
vacation
referrals would just drop off that you
know very few kids getting referred
same thing during the holidays or during
school vacations we would see a drop
that hasn't happened at all this year
there's no
predicting this other than to say we see
it go up and up and up
with referrals so um
i think it's important for us to
acknowledge this
and um i i know certainly throughout the
department
and and in you know children's
behavioral health
what we're really thinking about and
considering is you know this is where we
are now but we're not out of this yet
and and what what will the long-term
effects be
um over time um for children and adults
i don't think we really know that yet
um but you can see it's it's an area
that's very stressed
so so where are these kids physically
are they
are they um the ones that are in the
wait list are they back home
getting some wrap around services with
their parents or parent
or they sitting in an emergency room
hallway somewhere where
where are they physically mostly they're
in the emergency room
um but we have been working with um
children's behavioral health to have
some kids go home
with increased services and wrap around
sort of crisis
care in the home that work is ongoing
and i think
increasing you'll i'm sure you'll hear
more about that in future presentations
for some of the kids though they are
waiting at home
to return for an evaluation at hampstead
hospital
again i'm not a clinician but i just
can't imagine that to be good for kids i
i just gotta think they'd be better off
with all of their problems at home
than those same problems sitting in a
hallway in an emergency room so
i i i see mr norton's on the line i
i maybe uh he can tell us later what he
thinks but
hey uh representative wallner has a
question
thank you i guess i'm just having a
little
trouble with understanding this slide i
see
in at least sometimes i can't quite read
all these things
um in october it went up to 37
children in the wait list and then what
was this huge
dip down here in december
and then it got back up yeah
so through the fall um hampstead was
working to increase beds
so they were hiring actively hiring and
bringing more beds online
so i think that um that's what you see
during that time period they were able
to increase
admissions and actually i think we show
that in a future slide that they have
increased um
access a number of beds as well as
they've increased admissions just period
then at that point in december where you
see that
you know sort of that off there and then
that dramatic climb up
um at that point they were full and and
it's sort of this repeating pattern that
you see here here at new hampshire
hospital
we put beds online we fill them and then
we have trouble discharging
and i think that's represented in this
slide as well as just the ongoing
thank you could have one follow-up yes
so does hampstead have the ability now
um at this point there are seven beds
um that are physically present at
hampstead
but not staffed so that's where we were
talking about we think that
in may new hampshire hospital will be
able to step out of that because they
have a provider returning from a
maternity leave
in may so that will open up an
additional
seven beds the other thing that is
i think it's fluid
you know as far as occupancy goes and
for children um is that for kids
some kids can't be in a shared room or a
semi-private
so for a number of reasons so that can
impact
hampstead's ability to admit they do
have a number
not all their rooms are are private many
of them are semi-privates
um so that is also just related to
acuity
that's some of um another thing that
they struggle with
for keeping kids safe but um and it's
another reason that some kids wait
a little bit longer in the e.d because
they specifically need a private room
thank you sure and then representative
you've earned you've earned the right to
just ask your questions without
having to ask for a follow-up i i won't
i won't stop you unless
it's gone too far but i don't think
you'll do that so
just you're welcome to have a natural
conversation
so this is the slide that shows um their
total number of admissions
so um they you can see they started
increasing actually back in july of 2019
you see the point in february where we
you see the increase there to 108
in march when we rapidly you know
started
utilizing the contract the drop-off that
you see in admissions there
i think that that represents that
initial
lull in referrals and i i think
maybe you all remember at the beginning
of it seems like forever ago but a year
ago
when this all started people weren't
going to the ed at all
so we saw a big drop-off in referrals at
the very beginning of the pandemic
everybody sort of hunkered down
and stayed home we saw the same thing at
new hampshire hospital with adults
referrals dropped but then um then they
picked up
again to the current level that you see
right now
represent walnut your hand is up is that
from the previous
conversation
okay sorry
so you know in summary we do think that
hampstead has done a great job expanding
their capacity
so this is the summary just regarding
children
again hampstead has steadily increased
capacity
but they've seen at the same time an
increase in demand
three of the past four months have had
higher referral rates than the preceding
spring or summer so comparing
year over year and hempstead is
accepting a comparable if not more
referrals than new hampshire hospital
ever did so that sort of speaks to
um the so this this last three bullets
are
um sort of i already said this um so
this idea that some kids require the
single room so that can
impact capacity they're having trouble
with kids waiting longer for placement
and covet 19 and quarantine issues have
been difficult with staffing
as they have at new hampshire hospital
that seems much better
both here at new hampshire hospital and
so if i were helping write this slide i
would add another bullet
about kind of a unacceptable level
of pediatric wait list
hanging out in emergency rooms instead
of
at home with wraparound services or an
admission
i mean that's that's that's i think
that's a major part of the summary of
where we're at
and we need to focus on that it really
is and that's
that's that's the reason we we um
started bringing kids back here
it's just such a crisis and such an
so key accomplishments and challenges
for new hampshire hospital
we've had a busy year we've been working
on a lot
um in circling back to our strategic
planning and metrics
we've been able to accomplish a slew of
targeted solutions to improve
performance
relative to our metrics we opened the
path center the philbrook adult
transitional housing center which we'll
discuss more in the next presentation
we executed the contract with hampstead
hospital for pediatric care
we've drastically improved our ability
to recruit and retain staff
we've increased census at new hampshire
hospital we've invested in crisis
prevention
training that has reduced employee
injuries and we've implemented a new
form of billing
for professional services that has
helped offset some revenue shortfalls
that came from contracting for pediatric
care
oh i want to just highlight one other
thing that may be of interest
we did a staff vaccine
implementation that we started in
december and at this point
about 80 percent of our staff have
received both doses
of coven 19 vaccine that has
dramatically um
improved our staffing
reduced illness it's it's really been
amazing so i think that's that was a
huge accomplishment for us and
i'm really proud of our staff who um
were proactive and wanted to
receive vaccine 20
remaining are almost all of them people
who've refused the vaccine
yes we have had since we
did our program we have had a few people
change their mind about receiving
vaccine
and we've helped them to register at a
fixed site
to get their vaccine and in addition to
that new staff
we're working that into our orientation
to help them
get their vaccine so i can i would
anticipate our numbers will increase
are you anticipating a need for
incentives to
vaccinate or coercion for to vaccinate
or are you going to
accept that some employees don't want
the vaccination
i think we will continue to educate and
i think that over time
as people see um co-workers receiving
vaccine
and they receive more information about
how safe the vaccine is like i said we
continue to have people change their
mind
and convert over so i don't think that
we will need to
there is a group of employees who just
absolutely
are adamant that they will not be forced
um to receive a vaccine
and you know that's okay we we keep um
educating but they have very strong
feelings
i'll say that thank you representative
you're not muted
uh okay thank you i appreciate the
answer i
i'm i'm anti-coercion
good um so these key accomplishments
um are here on the timeline that you see
in front of you
what we're most proud of is that we were
able to achieve
all of these accomplishments despite
having to react and respond to covet 19
and the numerous challenges that it
represented this is an absolute
testament to the dedication of our new
hampshire hospital staff
it's been nothing short of humbling to
be part of this hospital during this
period of time
i'm just very proud of of all these
ongoing efforts
so in summary you see our key challenges
here
front door for both adults and kids
backdoor and those details are listed
and then our operational and financial
challenges
um are listed here in regards to the
challenges the hospital has
there you know you you've seen that
those three categories
we everyone knows about the the
publicized challenge in the issue of
emergency room boarding of children and
adults
and as you said chairman it's not a new
problem
this has been an issue with meeting
demand
for years we continue to operate at full
capacity on a daily basis
through many conversations and analysis
of data we've come to realize that a
portion of our front door challenges
are actually caused by the backdoor
challenges that we've talked about
for fiscal year 2020 nearly half of the
patients at new hampshire hospital no
longer required acute inpatient care
but the community resources necessary to
safely discharge them
are limited as a result the hospital's
lack of ability to discharge contributes
directly
to the front door issue of not being
able to admit
lastly the hospital faces numeral
numerous
operational challenges relative to
recruitment and retention
we have furniture that no longer meets
infection control standards
and an aging building that doesn't meet
new infection control standards
these are challenges we've been working
diligently on such as executing new
contracts
to aid in staff recruitment and we're
currently underway with a four million
dollar renovation
that was approved as part of last
biennium's budget
uh question here is uh
do you do you already have um
an alternative process in place to where
front door admission requests are
evaluated to determine if they could
pass directly to go without coming
through the new hampshire hospital in
other words
that they they're they're awaiting
admission but maybe
it's it's possible to just bypass
admission and get them straight into the
back into the community
thank you that's a great question we do
we have what we call our admission
huddle
and that happens at least twice a week
if not more and during that meeting we
have a group that includes
our medical director jeff fetter myself
social work our admission staff we go
through
every referral that's that has been
received here at the hospital and we
talk about alternatives could they go to
a drf
could they go to a voluntary unit um
sometimes we have jeff reach out and
speak with the clinician at the hospital
and make recommendations
um to initiate treatment and and maybe
avoid
the hospital visit um some of the
referrals that we have
um and these are folks that are boarding
our um
substance use disorder primarily and so
you know we review those cases and again
talk through with the hospital
what an appropriate referral would be
because you know um
for those folks it's it's not obviously
not appropriate for them to come here
um but you know based on sometimes
behavior or people being under the
influence
we do get those referrals so yeah we try
to be really timely
and in making recommendations and
declining
admissions if it's appropriate
so this slide really talks about
you know how we um figure out care
basically um and and how to calculate
the work that we do
so while staffing specific benchmarks
and inpatient psychiatry
are really highly contextual we do
benchmarks
ourselves on a cost per day which we
felt was
the best way to sort of show a good
metric in terms of our
cost effectiveness or stewardship
so that's what this shows i like this
slide a lot
um i just would ask is that
government-owned hospitals
is that government-owned psychiatric
hospitals
so if we were to fund you at the average
that would be a that would be lots of
millions of dollars wouldn't it
yes
i think this really shows how lean we
operate
i'd be curious and just a rough order of
magnitude estimate
of what additional incremental money
would be needed
just to bring you up to average from the
governor's budget
we can we can calculate that it doesn't
need to be hard math
i'll get back to you representative
thank you um did you
have did the governor's budget fund you
at the level you requested and if
so did you have other prioritized needs
that were
either funded or not funded um
yes um that we were approved for what we
asked for and i'm i'll actually defer
to joe christie um to speak in more
detail
sure so um good morning everyone can you
can you hear me okay
okay um so yes um the budget that was
requested was funded
um when we go through the financials um
there are two
uh two things that we want to bring to
your attention today
one of them was kind of an item that
came up in
the final days if not i think the final
day of trying to finalize the budget so
it wasn't so much that it wasn't
um funded it just was one of those
things that was really hard to time
and get built into the governor's budget
so i will talk about that in a bit more
detail
in a few minutes here but yes what was
requested
so this next slide is um the slide that
talks about you know what if we got an
increase
um 5 and what if there was a decrease
most importantly i think that the decr
you know five percent decrease
the number one thing you need to know is
that we would have to decrease capacity
that's the only way that we could manage
that um
that would involve potentially layoffs
and hamper also hamper our ability to
meet regulatory standards we are joint
commission
um certified so that would be very
difficult
um if we got any problems do you have
any problems currently
do you have any problems currently with
your jc ah
certification no not currently we're
anticipating that they will come back
for our review
um sometime in the summer or fall it's
hard they
have gotten very much behind in their
survey and their their reviews because
of the pandemic
but we are anticipating that they'll
and you can see on the slide you know
what could we do if we got an increase
um so it's not
good it's obviously not good to not
pass a jcho certification
but but what happens to you if you
do you lose federal money do you i mean
what
i i'm not encouraging it i'm just asking
what what's the worst case here
i i can jump in here a little bit
heather if you'd like
from a financial perspective cms does
reserve the right to
stop paying all medicare claims i
believe they can also expand that to
include medicaid claims as well so
there's a significant financial impact
and then i believe they also just from a
uh oversight perspective can
pause things like admissions to the
hospital and so forth until
just to summarize i'm not encouraging it
so this next slide talks about our
staffing patterns
um number of positions and then the
percent of total positions
i think that um this is a great slide
because it really shows
how lean we function really you can see
that
our direct care staff represent you know
of our budgeted positions so we have
very few administrative staff
um and then support services i think you
know is really
in in range of you know industry
standards if not a little low
um again we we get a lot done
with a little so
members of the committee have asked on
these questions what your
vacancy rate is that's a great question
vacancy rate for mental health workers
is around
22 23 vacancy rate for rns
is um substantially worse that is around
and you're trying to make that up with
uh per diems
and just uh overtime per diems
over time travel nurses when we can get
them but it's
uh we're in the same workforce struggle
um that many hospitals are in right now
you know with the nursing shortage
and the effects of covet 19 so it's very
difficult
you think you have very many support
services people who have been sucked
into doing administrative work instead
and just aren't listed as administrators
no i don't i don't think so i think um
and joe
jump in if i'm not correct but these
support services staff
represent materials management
food and nutrition environmental
services
facility staff so it's i don't think
that there's
um sort of overflow into admin
the the only thing i might add to that
um our our financial team so our revenue
cycle
and our accounting teams are included in
that support services
category you know one could argue that
those are a bit more administrative in
nature but
still required functions of the hospital
nonetheless
sure but your actual hands-on clinical
people are all in the acute phys
psychiatric services line and that's got
about a 30
so next up is the financial summary and
joe maybe you want to talk a little bit
about this slide
sure um so uh just to provide some
context on these
uh these these graphs in the 2018-2019
biennium
the hospital collected a portion of its
revenue called dish disproportionate
share payments um
we use an acronym called dish to refer
to those
the hospital received those dish funds
as federal
federal income and the dish fund program
is a program managed by cms
and it's really intended to reimburse
uncompensated care
so new hampshire hospital is the largest
consumer of dish funds in the state
we have the most uncompensated care and
so in that in that biennium
those were logged as federal funds in
the 2020 2021 biennium
those funds were changed in how the
department managed them
so in in the 2018-19 biennium new
hampshire hospital was
unique in how the state paid
its its dish funds to new hampshire
hospital versus how those funds were
paid out to every other hospital in the
state
in the 2020 2021 biennium we made it the
same
so now every hospital in the state
receives their dish payments the same
way
and so that's really just resulted in
now medicaid
draws down the federal funds and then
they pay them as
other revenue to new hampshire hospital
um so i just wanted to highlight that
because it looks
like a very significant change in the
proportion of federal funding
between those two years but it's really
just a change
in uh definition almost so you'll see
that the general fund percentages remain
relatively the same
between those two years and then the
total of federal funds and other funds
from the 2018-2019 biennium
are pretty comparable to the total funds
in the 2020-2021 biennium
the federal funds in the 2020-21
biennium that are still there so that
you know the 3.8 million that was cares
act money that was paid directly to the
hospital so
these are not gopher funds these are
what are called provider relief funds
they were paid directly to every single
hospital through their billing
exchanges essentially and it's really
aimed at helping hospitals pay for pbe
helping them pay for costs associated
with screening services
testing services um treating individuals
with cova 19
buying new pieces of equipment or
improving their facility or their their
environment of care to meet a higher
level of infection control
and so that's what that little sliver of
federal funds is in the current biennium
in the sure
um are we going to have an opportunity
to use any
federal covert money for infection
control to replace some of that
furniture
that is a great question so we actually
have a couple of projects underway
and to answer your question yes we've
already replaced certain types of
furniture
and bought certain pieces of equipment
as an example we bought a uv light
machine
that we can stick in a room and
essentially decontaminate a room
in a matter of minutes which has been
really helpful
but we also have two projects we're
working towards one is putting uv light
equipment in our air handler
system and then one is also working to
remove
fomite surfaces on units so that would
be things like carpet
you know anything that is not a
anything that is a permeable permeable
barrier i guess is a good way to phrase
it so
we do intend on spending quite frankly a
majority of those funds on improving our
environment of care for
infection control standards okay try to
replace that furniture
i'm unmuted thank you mr chair there's a
sizable increase
uh for the next biennium in general
funds that we don't have
it's like 12 13 increase
why is it so sudden sure so the
the primary increases in uh general
funding
um is relative to positions so a portion
of it
is um wage increases that are scheduled
uh and then another portion of it is 30
new positions to help us increase census
on the former children's
unit so we have 30 new positions that we
created in this current year
we're actively recruiting to fill them
we requested
to have those converted into permanent
positions
in the upcoming biennium i believe that
the governor included those conversions
in his version of the budget and so
those are the the primary drivers of
increasing
uh general funds um we did not ask for
you know more equipment money or or more
supply money
or facility type maintenance expenses
it really pertains to to staffing
well we're finding that throughout the
hhs
and we just don't have the revenue to
sustain it
but what we're seeing is request thank
you
so follow up i have on that is um
i don't understand the logic behind
creating new positions or converting
positions to
permanent if we have a 30 vacancy
in the clinical care area anyways i
if if you can't fill what we got what is
the point
of of adding more more
uh fte spaces if you can't hire the
faces to begin with
so i think that's a wonderful question
um we've
as heather has alluded to we've worked
really hard to try to increase our
recruitment and retention practices
part of that were actually two items
that were approved in
it was either the the last gnc of
november the first gnc in december
relative to a wage enhancement for
mental health workers which i'm going
to talk about a little bit more in a few
slides here
but also some new ways of recruiting
staff so we've executed a
temporary to permanent staffing contract
with a staffing agency
so these individuals come to us on a
nine month temporary basis and after
which they would
you know hopefully assuming they do a
good job they would apply for one of our
positions
and we would hire them into that that
contract has seen
a pretty remarkable success up to this
point so
um i believe we've hired 24 individuals
through that process since december
uh that's a great great leap for the
hospital
and we're going to continue trying to
find creative and alternative ways to
fill the positions so uh
i think your your point is certainly
spot on of
you know do you need to increase
positions if you can't fill the ones you
have
but i do think we have quite a few uh
efforts and plans in place to try to
fill the ones that we have
and make sure that we can fill the new
okay i'll take that uh it
represented nordgrid it looked like
maybe you were trying to raise your hand
no no i wasn't
okay i just didn't want to miss you all
right
uh so there are two uh specific uh
uh challenges that we wanted to bring to
your attention uh relative to the
hospital so the first
um is relative to those dish funds i
mentioned so again this is a
cms managed program to reimburse
uncompensated care
in december of this past year
cms redefined the formula for
calculating uncompensated care
in a way that will most likely
negatively impact the hospital's
revenues
the uh the the new calculation
essentially excludes a
uh population of data that we were
previously including
uh so there's no issue with prior years
we've confirmed that issue
but we have some pretty significant and
complex outstanding questions
that we're seeking cms technical
guidance on
depending on the answer to those
questions this could be a
you know a a couple million dollar
revenue change
or a much higher uh revenue change so
we just wanted to point this out and
bring it to your attention
i don't anticipate having those answers
from cms
during the house phase so we will likely
be making a change request in the senate
phase
but we felt it was important to bring
your attention again this is a program
we don't have any control over
and it's probably also worth noting that
although this is a significant revenue
stream for the hospital
this is a program that's been under
continual threat of discontinuation at
the federal level so it's been proposed
quite a few times to start the process
of reducing
the amount of dish paid at a federal
level
and there's even been kind of uh
schedules um
that that are intended to bring it back
down to zero and discontinue the program
altogether
so um from a financial perspective this
is kind of a high risk
area for us over the next probably five
to ten years
but but this this recent change in
legislation um
will definitely impact us in the
upcoming biennium and uh
once we have those firm answers we'll be
able to come up with a firm number
uh and make an appropriate change
request so because
we have to do a markup uh what is a
reasonable
in your opinion a reasonable contingency
risk reserve for this
5 million i i would say
[Music]
yes yeah at a minimum i think it will be
2 million
that upper end is really it's really
tricky because the questions we're
asking
really changed the scope of that
our our dish consultants uh
have the same interpretation of the the
federal law change that i do
um but without that specific cms
guidance it's it's
i'm a little hesitant as you can
probably tell to give a hard number
um no i can tell and that's five million
a year
uh yes yep mr ripple would you kind of
keep track of that
because as we're talking about finding
money that that we may
we may want to have a plan for that as
well
yeah sure i will thank you sir
you want to go yep okay uh so the second
uh challenge we wanted to bring you
before you get going again before you
get going representative weiler has his
hand up is that is that
from the last time nope it's a new
question
what about collecting money from private
insurance or from the people that
are admitted from themselves uh is there
any money in this that's coming from
those people or from insurance
thank you that's a great question so we
do have a contract executed with blue
cross blue shield
um and contracting as a hospital with uh
commercial insurance carriers is a very
common practice so blue cross blue
shield
is uh the currently the only con
contractor or insurance carrier we have
a contract with
we have attempted to contract with a lot
of other insurance carriers
um we have not been overly successful in
that uh
and i i think there's a few reasons
there
so one is um a lot of the
a lot of the insurance carriers have
very few patients that come through our
building
so uh what we do in those scenarios is
what's called a single case agreement
where we call up the insurance company
we come to an agreement for the
the specific admission that is in
question um
and then we receive payment accordingly
um about 21
of the hospitals uh patients are have
some form of commercial insurance
uh the um when it comes to contracting
with insurance companies that's been an
ongoing challenge
um it is something that i've been
researching pretty hard
in the past couple of months i'm trying
to find uh
more definitive ways to um to make sure
we can execute these contracts
uh it's been a concern of mine uh as
i've
oriented to the organization so
we're definitely going to try um i
i think i think it's not something we
can
we can readily plan for at this point um
you know i
we've had uh almost eight months now of
negotiation
with optum uh we've approached harvard
pilgrim in the past
um we've we've approached cigna um it's
really just challenging to get these
organizations to uh to sign an agreement
with us and
if i'm being 100 house i think part of
it is because we're a safety net
hospital
and you know we're not going to turn
anybody away because of their insurance
so um i am um i am
actively working on trying to find ways
to tighten that up a bit
uh but it's it's it's not a
it's not a clear-cut solution or there
isn't a clear-cut solution i guess i
should say
i don't think we can keep afford to
giving away free care
when we're one of the wealthiest states
if these people have something we could
attach or
collect money from whether it's property
or whatever rather than just
keep giving away and keep expanding the
tax
tax costs to the to the people that
are not using these we've got to do
something thank you
i should also just share that um we do
uh so
so we do what's called a financial
eligibility assessment on every single
patient that enters the hospital
um we do a back you know essentially a
resource check to see what they
have for available funds and if they do
have a significant
amount of wealth whether that be
property
income savings accounts etc we do
work with the patient and or their
guardian
to make payment for the services that
they receive so we do collect self-pay
type payments from from any patient who
has the ability to do so
i didn't see a self-pay wedge in the
revenue bubble though
so that is uh considered a part of our
other revenue
i can certainly provide on our our
billing revenue side i could provide you
a percentage breakdown of how much comes
from medicaid how much comes from
commercial insurance
how much comes from self-pay if you'd
like that that would not be a problem
i'm just thinking about the slides you
showed showing
the fy 2223 and there there was no wedge
for self-pay
and so i'm just wondering if it was
overlooked or
or assumed to be part of something else
it's a part of
other revenues on that graph there's no
other revenue there is there
i don't i i don't recall in the 2223
seeing another wedge uh so
yeah if you want to go back heather so
in the
2223 pie chart here the blue section
is other revenue uh and so that consists
of
jeez i thought okay so that's my fault i
thought that was all federal
uh i missed i misheard when i saw this
slide
i apologize for the interruption because
i
i assume that was red was
state and blue was federal and that's
obviously a horrible assumption
not a problem
so um so moving on to the second concern
we wanted to bring up to
to your attention today uh so in
uh in that last gnc and
i think it was either november the first
one in december as i had mentioned
before
the hospital had brought forth a mental
health worker pay enhancement
and this was really a vehicle or a tool
and a series of efforts to try to
improve emergency room boarding
so the hospitals as you mentioned you
know we struggle with recruitment and
retention
we have a high vacancy rate we're trying
to find ways to close that gap
and so one of the ways that we've we
felt we might be able to do that was
with a pain enhancement for mental
health workers
mental health workers are frontline
staff they're the ones who really
uh operate on the units on a day-to-day
basis with all of the patients
they provide assistance doing a lot of
daily activities
they perform a lot of safety functions
safety checks and regulatory
governed functions um
uh and and they're they're really just
the the front line staff
for the hospital
an issue that we've we've come to find
is that the wages that we've been paying
we really compete with um
i would say uh less hazardous
or potentially easier type positions out
in the community so
before this enhancement took place
mental health workers were earning
between 12 to
13 an hour kind of starting out
after a few years they might make a
comparable wage to a fast food worker in
the concord area
uh and so you know we're really
struggling to to recruit at that level
uh knowing that there are some of these
other positions uh out there in the
community that people could
could achieve so i assume you're talking
about lnas not
rns um actually we're not even talking
about lnas in this instance so these are
unlicensed individuals
some of them do have lna licenses but
you do not need a license to be a mental
health worker
um so they they don't
they don't do a lot of um medical type
care they do
sorry i just wanted to understand what
that 12 to 13 dollars was that that's
that's pre-lna for the most part
correct correct um
are you offering those people um
any sort of education benefits so that
they start moving up the lna
yeah i can take that question so yes
um what happens when we hire a mental
health worker if they're
our person that has not had experience
it's it's multiple weeks of training
really in psychiatric care
um so it's you it's not really an
equivalent to an lna's you know scope of
practice so when lna provides you know
hands-on care medical
care vital signs things like that mental
health worker
needs to be trained on how to react in a
psychiatric crisis
how to have a therapeutic relationship
how to
um ensure safety of of
patients and staff because it can be
it can be a pretty intense environment
here for someone who's not
you know stable psychiatrically
particularly on admission
so they receive all of that training
once they are employees here we
absolutely work with them many of them
go on to pursue nursing
licenses particularly rn um psychiatric
nurse um licensure for sure
so that is something that we have been
working on
so you know this enhancement really was
part of not only attracting new staff
but retaining the staff that we had
because we you know found that we
you know invested all of this time in
training um
for these mental health workers in a
very specific role
um and then they were leaving um to go
you know
you know work in in an environment that
was easier whether it's target or
walmart
yeah so that's kind of why i like the
idea of an educational benefit that
gives them golden handcuffs to stay for
a few years after
achieving their rn or something yeah
another thing that we're working on
actually chuck bagley is our staff
engagement
director and we are developing an lna
program
in our curriculum that we will run here
at the hospital
in addition to that we're doing a lot of
outreach with
um nursing programs to see what creative
solutions we can come up with
to have it be to their benefit and to
ours to
to get folks through nursing school so
i would just mention that as far as
tuition reimbursement
the department does offer some tuition
reimbursement that
is budgeted within the human resources
budget for the whole department
which is something that we covered in
the office of the commissioner there was
several hundred thousand dollars in a
training line
um that was training for employees and
that is where
we would reimburse for tuition from and
that goes through governor and council
i hope that they incur an obligation
period after
accepting the money whether we can
enforce it or not i hope we're at least
asking for a couple three years after
they receive the money to stay
i don't recall but we could get you that
information
all right go ahead i'm sorry i i
interrupted you joe
oh no no problem it's a great question
um
so uh so this was approved um you know
recently and uh so once it was approved
we worked really hard to get it built
uh into the payroll system of the state
uh and then we started working uh to get
it built into the budget system
um and uh that process took
a lot longer than i i think um we would
have liked so there were some
interesting questions that came up of
does the 20 apply to just base pay does
it apply to base play plus
shift differential um you know we had to
sort through some of those nuances
and so by the time we really got this
built in for every single position into
the budget system
uh what really ended up happening was we
ran out of
days or time uh in the governor's phase
so
um so we were able to get it built in um
but when it
when we finally got it in uh it put us
over the really the general fund target
we were shooting for so
um given that we we transition it to be
other funded to keep the total budget
request
in line with the hospital's needs um but
uh
the challenge here is the hospital
doesn't have the ability to earn
uh more revenue because it's incurred uh
this cost
we really tying this back to uh trying
to increase
our ability to respond to the emergency
room boarding crisis
to increase census we need to increase
staffing
to increase staffing we need to improve
recruitment and retention
and so that's really the kind of the
cornerstone of where this
this idea came from in the 2021 uh
budget i do want to emphasize
um so because we had some vacancies for
the six months prior to this being
approved
um the department felt conf confident
that we could try to fund
the rest of fiscal year 21. 21 for this
enhancement and so we
we have so this is something currently
being paid
and but we don't anticipate those
vacancy dollars being available
in the upcoming biennium again because
we're we're taking such an aggressive
approach towards
approach towards recruitment and
retention um and you know some
we're seeing some some successes in
terms of that that
attempt to permanent staffing contract
we've executed so
so does it seem to me like you you're
wanting to tell us a dollar amount that
we need to anticipate being added
as part of this change request yes you
would you might go to the next slide
ruining so uh
and the secret but no i i appreciate
that so
um so these are the uh the numbers uh
for each
uh year of the biennium um you know
i certainly understand these are pretty
significant numbers especially in the
context of your opening remarks uh
chairman relative to to um goals for the
house uh house budget
so um but these are the fun uh these are
the amounts as it stands based off the
number of positions we have
and the positions that the enhancement
would apply to
um okay so so far it's feeling to me
like we need to be thinking about 20
million dollars
more over the two years for uh
the hospital that are not in the general
fund's budget
so so that's a significant amount of
money for us to
look for representative waller you had
your hand up
i kept talking do you have a question
man no this slide answered my question
thank you okay
well that's like real money so if we
could uh
get your help looking for it i i'd
appreciate it
certainly i i think you know we're gonna
i've scrutinized this uh ad nauseam with
my team we're gonna continue to
scrutinize it to try to see uh
if there are any opportunities um but
we're
we've done quite an extensive uh uh
dive at this point and so ultimately
this is this was the
number in the slide that i felt i had to
present
so then in terms of um our accounting
units
so um these are our accounting units uh
the first one listed here 6096 is
actually going to be
reviewed in a separate presentation um
we created a presentation just for the
path center knowing that it's a new
program and
and we thought it would just be helpful
to give you some extra context on that
um the remainder of these are all
accounting units for the hospital
um and so chairman would you like me to
open the budget book or the briefing
book first
i hit the budget book first okay
um
heather do you want to stop screen
sharing for a second
mr ripple uh before he continues
how do you think we're doing on time you
you see the big picture there
are we are we behind schedule at this
point it feels to me like
i'm running this a little are you good i
think
possibly you do have three more
presentations
that that is correct the next two that
heather and i will be presenting i do
think will be shorter
the path center certainly will be
shorter um
i i would like to be done i would like
to be done by
by three o'clock i don't know i'm
looking at everyone's faces on zoom i'm
not seeing anyone
freak out when i say three o'clock so um
okay
[Music]
you're not going to go through all 1374
pages of this
oh i'm sorry this is the briefing book
you know while you're getting ready
there um we've been we've been talking
for almost two hours i'm i'm thinking
maybe
uh the committee and the attendees could
use a
like a five minute bio break five ten
minute bio break
so so why don't you um
mr christie um get ready
and and then we'll we'll come back i i
have us at 11
23 we'll come back at exactly 11 30
after a bio break
i don't know mr ripple if you have to
put a recess sign up
kevin i believe heather and i are just
okay
mm-hmm
all right it's uh 11 30. do we have the
i i feel like romper room
i see keith
i see mary jane i see harry
okay i think i think we have a quorum so
um we don't see you
oh you don't nice
i mean hopefully i don't have anything
in my teeth that was a pretty quick
sandwich
um all right mr christie you're
you're up okay um so i'm
uh sharing the um the budget document
now
but really starting at the accounting
units relative to the presentation we
just had would be
starting with 8400 here i'm happy to
so i i think you've explained in the
slide deck
why expenses 10 and 12
are going up in the biennium by a
correct it's um in in the accounting
unit 8 400 that is solely because of
increases
uh scheduled increases in wages but
wouldn't that
if you're if you're successful
um so it's somewhat depending on the
i would say a accounting unit but so in
8400 for example
this is administrative staff who are
just
receiving essentially a step increase in
their pay so it's
a higher cost for the same same amount
of hours worked
and then in other sections so 8750
which is our really our direct care
accounting unit
that's where the significant increase is
represented in from a payroll
perspective
and that's driven by both increases in
wages
but also increases in position counts
yeah
i'm sorry so it took me just a moment to
get my head
into the right space here so you're only
adding one fte on your permanent
classified
but you're driving your personnel costs
up
substantially in the biennium for the
one extra person plus step increases so
we're talking about 8 400 at admin right
joe if i can just add there i believe
that there were unfunded positions
and 20 and 21 which are now funded in 22
and 23.
so i believe that's also part of that
increases some previously unfunded
positions
okay do you want to move us back to that
slide one go back one
sure because that's where it is that's
where the money is
so i'm going to let mr ripple speak
first and then
and then representative walner had her
hand up and
weiler and nordgren thanks the one thing
i wanted to point out that you will see
agency-wide and budget-wide
is personnel costs in
22 might appear somewhat high because
there are 27 pay periods instead of 26
that's that explains part of it
all right so uh representative was that
it mr ripple that's a good ad
yes thank you uh mr or excuse me
um thank you so i the 20
um increase in wages
probable that you say we might need to
anticipate
does not it would not um affect this
page is that correct
uh so that's correct the total value
for that pay enhancement is built into
this budget it's more of a source of
funds issue
so it's currently funded as a hundred
percent other revenue sources
not uh general funds and the challenge
there is we we can't earn that money um
yeah we we don't have an ability to earn
that money okay
thank you thank you representative
uh thank you i see that the
class 10 went down in 2021 i assume
that's because of vacancies
and you say you're trying to recruit and
so you're going forward you're
assuming full uh
membership or full uh full
positions i don't think we can assume
that we can't afford it
so i wouldn't be so quick to if you can
personnel then you've got to continue
that because
we cannot afford a 15 20 increase which
you're showing here there's no way
unless you're going to go out get some
i certainly under understand that i
think um
i think the the thought processes
um for at least for us we're really
trying to make some fundamental changes
to emergency room boarding and we feel
that some of these changes would be the
things we need to to really try to start
so that might be really a good thing for
us to go over
after we get out of the heat of battle
on the budget
um you know where we have a little bit
more time to
reflect on on on the big plans
um representative waller your hand is
still up did you have a question still
no i just keep forgetting to put it down
representative norgren you had your hand
up and yours is down now so do you have
oh we may have lost her altogether
because she was there with her hand up
and now
i don't see her or hear her um
okay i don't have my hand up
oh okay all right um
put your hand up anytime uh so
so the other thing that jumps out here
is uh expense
zero six zero benefits and i think what
you're going to tell me
is that this is a fixed percentage that
you're given by
somebody else and you have to apply it
to your
yup that's correct it's a fixed
percentage based off class 10
18 19 um
and uh 59 if there was one
but yes that's that's a percentage uh
given to us by
the department of administrative
services um
and uh i believe i i
tuned into a prior presentation and i
know this is a question that came up
these numbers do look consistent with
i don't see any other questions if you
want to continue
okay um so
8410 is is really our supportive
services
accounting unit so that you know
environmental services
our facilities teams our food and
nutrition department
again increases really being relative to
to to payroll
it kind of in a general synopsis of the
hospital's budget the
you know i think we mentioned before
that um you know 72 percent of our staff
are direct care but i think
proportionally just the uh payroll to
to uh other lines of the budget um is
is quite high so um
we don't we don't uh we didn't budget
anymore for equipment we didn't budget
anymore for
supplies we kept all of those flat
[Music]
and some of them you know some of the
other expenses we work hard to try to
either reduce or at least
keep them keep them flat so i see the
food institution money is there
is there should i be seeing a furniture
line here
uh so that is actually in 8400 so
um this class 30 equipment line right
here
that is relative to any equipment or
furniture for the hospital
and this this value comprises the
hospital's entire
equipment and furniture budget
okay and what does that represent ten
percent replacement
5 replacement 100
um i would say off the top of my head i
so it's it's pretty challenging most of
our
replacements year over year are when
things are hitting the end of useful
life when we're not
um and there are quite a few pieces of
equipment we drag out beyond
the manufacturer's you know stated use
of life so long as it
keeps functioning and it's properly
serviced by a biomedical engineering
service
i'm looking back at 8410 and there's a
such a tiny amount for 0.37
technology hardware yeah
that's kind of a mistake if that's
supposed to be in somebody else's budget
and accidentally ended up here
uh so i'm not a hundred percent
i can't recall exactly how we arrived at
that number class 38 and 37
are um two new lines to new hampshire
hospitals budget we used to charge these
uh i believe to class 30
uh or class 20 depending on the dollar
amount
uh and we felt that these classes
offered a greater specificity
on some of the items we were buying so
we included them in this upcoming budget
i'm just saying it looks like it's
either a mistake or it's not enough
money
i think i i i think it's the latter
um i think it's not enough money but i
think that's because we wanted to just
create the class line
but also know that um
know that we were trying to keep things
uh relatively flat
telecommunications you you you spend
that with
doit or do you have direct contracts
uh that is really through doit
um i would say the only i still think
it's a doit service though but
um you know cable and internet and
things like that in the building
um i believe that's the majority of that
line
all right well thank you i see
representative erf with the question
here
what is the transfer to other state
agencies
great question so the state office
campus police department so at new
hampshire hospital the state
office police department is actually
housed inside our hospital
um and we require their services on
occasion um
in in working with some of our patients
so this is really for the cost
of that police department
and so that's a transfer to the
department of safety okay
wow how do you measure service provided
or service requested for this line
do you have a measure or is that just a
number that you all agree on
uh so uh and heather jump in here if i i
misspeak but i
believe we really try to maintain at
least two officers on site
at all times uh really for safety
reasons
so um you know in scenarios where an
individual might escalate
to a point where we require their
assistance we really try to have at
least two people on site 24 7.
yeah i would agree with that we do have
a dispatch
person that's also part of that but
that's
really very necessary at night in
particular when we don't have
receptionists
on duty that dispatch person handles
emergency calls from the units and
and release that to the officers so
yes very good people need to be safe
um all right thank you are there i have
there's another question by
representative earth
now my bad i should take my hand down
sorry okay
all right uh you can continue
okay uh so
uh 8750 again is really where all of our
direct care
costs are incurred
again the majority of this increase is
um
i'm happy to happy to take any questions
yeah so
i think one of the consequences of
putting the plus and up the 30
in the prominent classified is that it's
increasing your your 0-10 expense line
and i i still don't quite get
your logic on why you're creating 30
more spaces when you can't
fill the 438 you already have
i don't get it and and and if that
shouldn't be done
that would that would lower uh the 0-10
personal services line in a way that
that is that is correct i think our our
logic behind
those 30 positions um is that
we intend to fill them and we are
actively changing
the rate in which we are able to recruit
and we're actually
i would say not just hoping we're seeing
results in that
that realm as well um so again between
just december and now we've hired 24 new
mental health workers
through um through a attempt to
permanent contract that we've executed
uh and that's a that's a significant
increase you know at the time we
executed that contract we had 35 mental
health worker vacancies to
to so we've we filled 24 of them um
up to this point um and that you know
we're going to continue to try to find
alternative ways to recruit for
positions like nursing and so forth
so not to nickel and darmian but if fy22
showed a ramp up instead if let's say it
was
445 or 450 instead of 468 as a ramp up
that would
that would take down some of your
expense lines and maybe
actually fit a recruiting reality better
is that possible um
we could certainly think through that
exercise the one thing i would be
hesitant about so
so this is where we really have to dig
into a staffing model on our side
is just that we can't partially staff a
unit per se so we either have to staff
it or not staff it
you know it's we'd have to really i
think dig into that and do a pretty
significant analysis to see what that
right what that right amount might be if
there's some sort of middle ground
well i'd appreciate that because it
sounds to me that you're
sitting at around 3 30 actual bodies
now 330 to 350 and so that's a lot of
successful recruiting
but um but you but if you could really
look at that i'd appreciate it
representative wallner you've had your
hand up
uh yes thank you so on this page
could we take a look at the uh line 102
absolutely would you like to yeah could
you just
just outline for us what's in there
sure um so class 102 in this accounting
unit the primary expense is the
dartmouth contract
so it's a contract for all of our
physicians and nurse practitioners
um at the hospital all of the
psychiatric providers
so that's a significant portion of that
line another aspect of that line is our
travel nurse contracts
so on occasion we're able to secure
travel nurses
it's been less frequent since the
pandemic the cost of travel nurses has
has skyrocketed due to the pandemic uh
and so
we don't we no longer really have
competitive rates there um
we tried to do a rate increase recently
and and that hasn't really worked out
well for us either so
um but the the second portion of that is
uh the travel nurse contract um i'm
trying to recall if there's any other
contracts in that line
um oh and the the attempt to permanent
staffing
contract that i mentioned earlier as
well a portion of that contract is paid
out of this line
and then a portion of it is paid out of
the past center class 102.
so um those i think those three
contracts are
comprise the total dollar values you're
seeing there
okay thank you yep i was going to guess
hampstead
hospital contract i i would have been
wrong
where's the hampstead hospital contract
hampstead is in
so this line right here you can see
because it's only been a partial year in
fiscal year 20
we spent you know 330 000 last year um
uh we didn't have anything per se
budgeted
um because it was so new but we have
spent money there
um and then really it's a it's a
structured contract so we anticipate
between 1.2 and 1.6 million a year
are you going to show up with an fy 2021
problem that we need to transfer money
for
um no uh not for the hampshire contract
so
the way that money was appropriated we
were given five million
uh that was non-lapsing money um
and so uh so you know it's it's
after 87.50 we just have some um
smaller accounting units relative to
specific functions we're either required
to manage by law
um i did also want to mention obviously
the hospital has a trust fund so we have
various accounting units for the trust
fund
the trust fund is is managed by a trust
and really
does a lot for patient discharging so
the committee
uses that fund for things like buying
individuals
shoes upon discharge or paying first
months rent to try to get them out of
the hospital
you know those those types of things
really helping to enhance and facilitate
discharging
and then occasionally doing
doing random purchases on behalf of
patients in some capacity to improve
their experience
my my left eye had surgery so i'm just
having a little trouble focusing
what which line item are you referring
to
um sure so um let's see
so it's a bit challenging i see it i see
it
so um this this line right here is the
primary spend
out of our trust fund there are multiple
accounting units
that we use um with trust fund money so
i think there's like five or six
um but this is the primary spend out of
the trust fund right here
that's a huge change 738 projected for
this fiscal year
down to 183 so what what what's going on
there
um so that is a combination of
um the the discharging spend that i had
mentioned
um and then the trust trust fund after
uh not getting uh furniture and
renovations approved in a prior biennium
uh took it upon themselves to uh
purchase uh and try to replace some
things that that were deemed a
safety hazard for patients
okay so we spent trust fund money on the
furniture we needed for infectious
control purposes
um not all of it uh just just and it
wasn't so much for infection control it
was more to do with
um with uh safety um it was
things that could break and be used uh
used as a weapon or things of that
nature
in the army we used to refer to the
color of money
that you couldn't use different pots of
money for different things and so i
would just assume you're
making sure that you all are spending
appropriately from the
correct pots that is correct so the the
trust fund cannot be used to supplant
operating dollars
um and we coordinate uh with the
charitable trust uh organization on on
doing that
um or on managing our trust fund i
should say
um it was really uh relative to patient
safety issues and knowing that the funds
had been requested in a prior biennium
that's that's where that purchase came
from so but yes we we do
actively uh work to make sure we're
spending these these monies in the most
appropriate way
thank you
uh and that's that's really it for the
hospital
okay are there any uh questions from the
committee
i'm not seeing any okay we're gonna try
something new
um i see that we have about 25 attendees
and we'll see how many of you are
listening i guess um
but uh if you have any comments or
questions
uh go ahead and raise your hand and mr
ripple and i will recognize you and
bring you in
if you are a lobbyist i ask that since
we can't see your badge
that you identify yourself as a lobbyist
uh are are there any hands raised
mr norton if you're if you're out there
i i kind of asked you a question
earlier about uh
pediatric care and having kids uh
bordered in the in the hospitals in the
ers or
if you're there i'd like to hear your
thoughts
hi mr chairman and committee members um
uh thank you for the opportunity to
speak i thought that
um heather and her team did an excellent
presentation
um obviously um
the situation with children is pretty
dire right now um and
as was represented it's a little bit
scary
with the pandemic not knowing um
where these numbers are going to go in
the future
and that's a real cause for concern
obviously the
the 10 additional beds at new hampshire
hospital was
a critical move albeit it pushed the
adult numbers up
and you know one of the things that i'm
a little bit unclear
about and and maybe um heather could
could answer this is that when we
contracted with hampstead as a state
um there were essentially two two
in-state options for
children with psychiatric inpatient
needs
one was new hampshire hospital and one
was hampstead
so when we contracted with
hampstead then there just became one
option
hampstead and it's unclear to me whether
we
net resulted in an increase in beds or
whether that
combination of um of contracting with
hampstead resulted in a decrease of beds
overall
for kids um so that that was one of the
questions i had and then
um you know a couple other points that i
that i wanted to make was
that um i just wanted to
follow up the comments that um mr
karisti made about insurance companies
and
and commercial insurers paying this is a
significant issue in my mind and
something that we nominate new hampshire
and others have been trying to
address in a variety of ways the new
hampshire insurance department does have
a
a mental health and addiction advisory
committee but
um i i think as he alluded to one of the
concerns that i have is that
um the the commercial insurance
companies are
they have an obligation to their members
to provide for
capacity for inpatient and outpatient
care
and it seems to me that part of what's
a an attempt on some level to push the
care of people with serious mental
illness
onto the state and
and and that care should be born across
a number of different places should be
born across
insurance companies should be hospitals
certainly the k
the state has um has some responsibility
for that
as well but um but the fact that we're
having so many folks in our emergency
department waiting for boarding in my
mind indicates that
there's not adequate network capacity
and
um i applaud the fact that you know that
anthem does contract with new hampshire
hospital but i question
even you know if the numbers are low why
the other insurance companies don't
um and one other question i have is
is about um the
um the imd exclusion and sorry i'm
having a brain
brain cramp about the acronym um it's
the institutional mental disorders
exclusion which in the past has
precluded
use of medicaid funds to pay for
inpatient psychiatric hospital care
by at the federal level but there is now
a waiver process that's
available for that i believe and
um and i'm not sure how that plays into
current um or future
um budget issues so those are just a few
of the thoughts i have
really appreciate all of the questions
that that
the committee asked and uh and the
presentation that was given
so let me follow up on your last item
first
and that is uh who who within dhhs
owns the medicaid waiver process that
might
pursue a medicaid waiver for the new
hampshire hospital
for institutional care so i i can
actually speak to that
that topic uh we've we've actually been
researching that waiver process for
a little over a year now at this point
um
it uh so the the imd exclusion rule that
was uh that can reference
um essentially for patients between the
ages of 22 and 64
who have medicaid um their their
care essentially cannot be uh reimbursed
in an institute for mental disease which
is
which is kind of what new hampshire
hospital is is called from a regulatory
perspective
and so for that portion of patients a
lot of that care goes uncompensated and
that gets into those dish payments i was
talking about earlier
so the waiver process there is a new
waiver to try to get around
that piece of law to some degree and
it's a portion of the social security
act
that that creates the imd exclusion rule
so the waiver process would allow for
payment
uh i believe it is up to uh for length
lengths of stay
up to 60 days uh after 60 days to oh
sorry so quote a famous boxer no moss no
moss
just to keep us going i wanted to make
sure i i knew that somebody owned
the research problem and it sounds like
you're all over it
and you don't have an answer yet and i
just
add very quickly to that that this is
also part of what the commissioner and i
presented on in the department overview
presentation
that we are hoping to have alvarez and
marcel which we refer to as a
i thought mr norton asked a good
question i had assumed if we were going
to hampstead
we would have been increasing our
pediatric
psychiatric beds on the net
did we do that or did we somehow reduce
it accidentally
we didn't reduce it was um a slight
increase and by slight i mean by just a
couple of beds at the time that we
um pursued that contract we had seen
historically that occupancy here at the
hospital had been dropping
from 2017 into 2018. um when we looked
at census trends
um at the time again pre-pandemic
making the transition to hampstead um
provided enough bets based on the data
that we had about referrals
and patient days so when we
when we created the contract with
hampstead at that point we were only
occupying
12 beds here for kids at the hospital
and not at full occupancy i mean we were
running with a census of
three four five children on that unit um
so when we created that contract with
hampstead
part of what we talked about was
that they would occupy then a vacant
unit
so upon doing that that was sort of a
wash that vacant unit was i think
15 or 17 beds and again with
closing that 12 bed unit that we had it
seemed like
a number that would work based on trends
um with census and again that has all
changed just during the pandemic
so at the time that we put the contract
together it seemed like there were there
would be enough access
to children at hampstead not a huge
increase in number of beds
but we didn't feel that they were needed
and then you had a second question in
there but mr norton i
i wanted to come back and it just seems
to me um
that we do a lot of damage to kids
who are hurt and need some mental health
services and then we're keeping them
aborted in the er and i would like to
know
um relatively speaking
since we're not talking optimally
speaking but relatively speaking
would we be better off just getting
these kids back home
with some kind of wrap-around services
albeit minor
than to hang on to them into the in a
boarding s
boarding operation thank you for your
question mr chairman
and um that is a key question and you're
going to hear more about that this
afternoon when
the children's bureau of behavioral
health presents and
you know to to heather's point one of
the challenges that we face as a state
is how we how we uh determine capacity
for inpatient beds versus
community capacity and community
capacity to your point
is the desired outcome we want children
to stay with their families in their
communities
in their schools with natural supports
there is a fast forward program which
has been
developed which you'll hear more about
this afternoon which focuses on
children that are at risk of placement
outside the home and does provide those
that level of wrap around care
again don't want to exclusively pick on
the insurance companies but you know
one of the issues is is getting
insurance companies to pay for
um in-home levels of support
particularly if they're not
master's level or licensed clinicians
but
to your point yes that is the goal is to
you know to provide as much
community-based in-home supports as
possible but that's also
you know i don't want to minimize the
acuity of some of the children that are
showing up
in our emergency rooms right now in
terms of their need for
inpatient um treatment all right
thank you i'm not seeing any other
participant hands up did did you get all
your questions
answered mr norton yes
thank you for uh stepping up i see a
hand raised by somebody
a panelist their representative verve
so i know i thought you said there are
no more panelists i can wait
no there i i you are a panelist that
that's
it's good to be a panelist it's the
attendees who are
in the uh in the cheap seats
just a quick question i must have must
have missed it what is the
1696 a community residence that's new
apparently with
35 employees that's going to be our next
presentation
oh i thought that was part of the
hospital okay it's it's part of the
hospital's
agency number but we felt because it's a
new facility and a new program we would
we would do a separate presentation on
it
okay okay
uh i think we're ready to go uh try to
try to give us a 30 to 45 minute
bite at the apple and and we'll break
for lunch
uh at that point uh hopefully that's you
got a natural cutoff point for that
great so
are you seeing my screen right now for
the path center
great okay um so i actually think that
this presentation will be
um a bit quicker than the others it's
shorter
um it's a brand new program
here's the agenda the overview of what
i'll talk about it's very similar to the
one that we presented for new hampshire
hospital
and um i think i might need
thank you all right thanks
so um contact information is listed here
so the funds for for the path program
uh were appropriated as part of hb4 in
the 2021 biennium
the department used a portion of those
funds to establish the path center which
is our 16 bed transitional housing
facility
located in the former philbrook building
here on campus we opened in september of
and right now the path center again
serves as an active discharge location
for patients who are at new hampshire
hospital but are clinically stable
and are awaiting housing in the
community
where's that physically located i i'm
imagining a building
or am i looking imagining it wrong
um it is physically located over at the
former
children's hospital the philbrook
building which in between
housed a professional licensure in the
board of nursing
do you know what building i'm talking
about now i imagine it's on the dhhs
campus somewhere
it is it is it's on the um it's on
clinton and fruit on sort of on the
corner there
i'm sorry what i said it was probably a
beautiful building in 1880
i think it was around a little bit later
than that joe was it built in the
60s maybe 60s or 70s
so this slide just represents where
the path program sort of fits in with
the inpatient mental health system so
you can see
that it is a direct discharge location
for us for
you see here the mission and the vision
of the path center
and really this program is about
allowing patients to be in the least
restrictive environment that they can be
you know according to what their
clinical needs are so
um folks that are referred to this
program are uh you know psychiatrically
and medically stable
and they literally are waiting for
appropriate housing but that is
independent housing
that they're waiting for so um in order
to not
again to to you know improve our
discharge process and and work on the
the back door issue the idea was that
the path center could move folks out of
new hampshire hospital
and then they work um closely with
housing specialists within this program
so so i have to ask it this way are are
you saying that these are folks that are
would otherwise be homeless and have
nowhere to go
and so we're holding them until
some kind of a housing arrangement can
be found for them so they
sleep under a roof at night or or or are
you talking about a specialty kind of
housing
so it is specialty in that there is
additional programming so i would think
of it more of a
as a step down from new hampshire
hospital so
most of these patients so they have
achieved clinical stability they don't
require
hospital level of care anymore but they
are working on a bridge voucher they are
trying to find apartments they are
working on employment
they are needing to get connected with
community mental health centers
so with the step down to the path
program they continue that work
and then discharge to a setting that's
going to allow them to continue to be
stable
okay but they're not necessarily
homeless they may have
their own apartment or house somewhere
but we're still looking to give them a
level of care
most of them have not found an apartment
yet but they're in the process with the
bridge voucher
and looking for um affordable housing
but i would say
i no i will make an exception to that we
have had a couple of instances where
we've had patients discharged to the
path program who were
going to be returning to their parents
home
but they had additional work that they
were doing with counselors
and also working on employment so we
have had that be
thank you they're all are they all
they're all coming directly from new
hampshire hospital
currently yes they are yep um we have
talked about it being a potential
um placement location for other types of
transitional housing that need a step
down
from their programs but right now we're
keeping them full with referrals from
new hampshire hospital
so i remember in the past
people from new hampshire hospital the
staff they're talking about
um people who had
stayed in new hampshire hospital for
many many years
and are we have we been able to move
some of those um clients
to the path program
seemed like there were some people who
had been in there for for several
several years
because there was no place for them to
go i i would say that that
the patients that are being referred to
path are not part of that population
so that population that you're talking
about really has
more special needs and an increased
level of service
so it's not at the hospital level of
care but path is much more um
more independent than that so many of
those folks that were waiting
were waiting for um programs that are
more like nfi
that are more intensive services or
maybe they are needing
a group home so that that population
path doesn't so much serve but path
definitely serves people
who are homeless or pursuing housing
and that's extending their length of
stay so we are able to get get
get patients discharged quicker with
utilizing path beds for that very
specific population
uh yes uh thank you heather um
i thought there were also transitional
housing availabilities in communities
around the state are those included in
your discussion
or are they overseeing by the department
or
what yes yes i believe that those
residences that you're talking about are
typically
either run by a contract agency like nfi
or some of the community mental health
centers
run residential programs like that and
those are overseen
by the department of behavioral health
so they're not overseeing directly by me
i only oversee path but the department
oversees the other programs
okay thank you very much so for you to
release a patient from the path center
to say something like a group home uh
do do do do those uh
sort of charitable organizations do they
have to comply with the federal
housing first policies in order that for
them to
qualify as a housing partner with you
so patients that are being discharged
from path are either
going to um their home with their with
their guardian or
maybe their parents or most often
they're going into independent housing
in an apartment with a bridge voucher
they're not typically going to another
um transitional housing
location does that make sense
yep and then and then do you keep any
stats on if any of these are veterans
actually i don't think we have yet but
that's a great point
because you know again those are
additional for veterans
that's a whole other path towards
housing that could be pursued
so that's definitely something we could
do
so again just um just so you have an
understanding of what you know the path
program does and what it does not do
so it's transitional in nature people
are not living at path for
long periods of time they are supervised
for their medication
there are continued therapeutic
psychiatric services that are provided
uh there's inten really the biggest
thing they do is this intensive case
management discharge planning
which is working towards finding housing
and employment
and then coordinating that transition to
the care of the community mental health
center
that's very important one of the things
that came up when we pulled path
together was this question of does that
mean that everyone that discharges to
path
now is a concord resident and now is
part of riverbend
and they are not our goal is for
for these patients to get to their home
communities wherever that may be in the
state
so that's something that the housing
specialists and the social workers work
very closely with these patients on to
reconnect them
with that community mental health center
we don't do
it sorry go ahead no i i thought you're
taking a break there what i was just
going to ask what the
youngest age of a an acceptable
patient or client would be if they're
over 18
it's certainly acceptable to to be over
at the path program i would say
we've had a range of ages of referrals
but really anyone over 18 can can work
and you're obviously accepting uh all
genders
you're not uh do you have i'm i'm
thinking about the housing
facility at the path center and whether
or not
there's appropriate segregation
so they're all private rooms but the the
wings
um there at the unit are co-ed um and
then
there are um shower and toilet
facilities that are you know assigned
have you had any incidences of of
harassment
no or patients all getting along like
brother and sister
we've had a couple of incidents with
patients
that upon discharge maybe had some
increase in psychiatric symptoms
that needed to be managed by the team
there
again it's a big change from this very
restrictive environment here at new
hampshire hospital to then to be at the
path program
we've had a couple of patients that have
been readmissions to new hampshire
hospital based on that
so we haven't had any incidents of
violence or anything like that but we
have had incidents where patients
destabilized
and needed to come back i'm just worried
about the
security of of the
patients that are not as strong and able
to protect themselves in case they have
somebody come
molest them i mean if it's a co-ed wing
you have co-ed issues and so i'm just
hoping you're on top of that i think
it's a great point
our campus police are also supporting
the path center
um so we have close communication with
them
they are at the ready if there's
anything needed it's from a security
standpoint the other thing is each of
these patient rooms are private rooms
and um they are locked the resident has
the key
to their room and um a step you know
staff has a key to get into the room but
otherwise there is the ability
um to have absolute privacy so when
their door is shut it's secure and it's
locked
and we also have staff there 24 7 so
there is
an ongoing level of supervision all the
time
so this is the team um the leadership
team that's
covering for path so you can see joe and
i are on this slide ellen the point is
our chief operating officer and so she's
very involved from the aspect of making
sure that
support services are in place as needed
and then our new directorate path is
debbie robinson and
she's a long-standing state employee
and she just started last month but
so you asked about about data and we
just really started collecting that it's
so new
still that i think it's going to be
really interesting to look at this year
over year but
for now this slide just shows you our
gradual ramp up
to get to um you know
occupancy here at at the facility so
um we did go a little bit low and slow
over the first couple of months but i
think that was
important and that was also related to
us filling positions
so to maintain safety we sort of had to
i think it's too soon to say what the
length of stay
will be that that's what this slide
represents just based on
um our short period of time of
collecting data
um but like the slide notes you know
any or all of these days could have been
incurred at new hampshire hospital had
so in summary yeah no
earlier you guys had a a
a national benchmark for the average
cost of a psychiatric hospital
per patient day and i'm just curious if
there's an equivalent benchmark
for this facility or if you've
begun worrying about calculating your
per patient per day
costs yeah we have started doing that
and
and joe can speak to that i think where
we were trying to show
you know where the value was in this
program was in comparing it to what it
cost per day for a patient to be here
at new hampshire hospital compared to at
the path program
joe do you want to talk about the daily
rate for path
sure um so there is no uh
real clear or solid benchmark that we've
been able to identify path serves a
relatively
niche population um but to heather's
point
in this presentation in a few slides
from now we do have that uh
that cost per bed day benchmark uh
compared to the national benchmark new
hampshire hospital's cost
and then the cost per bed day at the
path center to give you a sense of
um kind of the the cost benefit
trade-off of having that patient be at
the hospital versus being at the path
center
so this is a timeline of of really the
work that we did around opening
this program it was a pretty huge
accomplishment again
um in the context of the past year um
here at new hampshire hospital and
everything
that we have um sort of overcome and
challenges
but you can see um it really was
over the over the course of the summer
um in 2020
um got the funding built the accounting
unit
created positions started recruiting
like crazy
um the renovation of the facility was um
huge you know that was that we we needed
to work
very very quickly um to get contractors
in there and get that work done
um and then ultimately in september we
got our approval from the fire marshal
to occupy and we opened
and and as you can see in the previous
the slide just represents our challenges
short term and long term
ultimately what we would like path to be
is
um a structure to be replicated
throughout the state
so we thought you know if this is um if
if we can build this model you know can
we duplicate this over and over again
hopefully with partners like community
mental health centers
that can get more of these locations
throughout the state
understanding that there is going to be
some variability
in the level of service that's provided
at the path program it is definitely a
step down from new hampshire hospital
we do provide service but there are a
number of patients that we have here
that are not appropriate for path
because they need a little bit more or
they need a longer
stay in in a housing situation that has
support
representative
um thank you actually my my question was
where are you going to try to replicate
this in other some other areas
have you identified any areas yet in the
areas of the state that
we haven't identified a specific area
yet but the
you know our feeling is that um
certainly
um in the lakes and in the north country
that it seems like that there could be
good utilization in those areas
um but you know census census-wise we do
have a
a large you know population that is in
the manchester area and nashua
there are other transitional housing
options that are already there though
um so i think it really will come down
to um
who can we partner with you know for in
particular from potentially a cmhc
um and work closely with in an area
where it's needed but
i think our general feeling was perhaps
lakes region or the north country
it's just it's just soon to say great
thank you
so i think this slide speaks to your
your question
um chairman edwards just around you know
how do we how can we figure out value
here of what we're doing um
so joe spoke to this there there really
aren't any benchmarks but what we can do
um is try to do some calculations based
on
um that value of the patient you know
not being here at the hospital level of
care
so i think this slide does a good job in
showing that
so like a green eye shade question um
does that 729 include the amortization
of all the renovations and one-time
licensing costs
or is that just um direct
operating costs i believe those are
operating costs correct joe yeah
that is correct that is correct okay so
if we wanted a fully loaded number we'd
take a look at
the amortization of the renovations
would that have a material difference on
that number
i don't think it would if i remember
incorrectly i believe our renovation
budget was 170 thousand
so it it wasn't so much a massive
renovation or overhaul of the space
it was more about the timeline we had to
do it in
so it was you know uh getting numerous
contractors in the space at the exact
same time
and really trying to stand this program
i didn't see whose hand went up first
but representative nordgren here on top
thank you very much chair um so this
page would be nice if we also could see
what the cost comparison would be if
these people were kept
in the state hospital
so this is obviously like a step down
unit
and it's costing less which is freeing
up beds in the state hospital
it'd be good if we could just see what
the comparison would be
for all these numbers across the board
thanks yeah you know i think that
it also will be helpful to have another
year you know of operating
that we can really sort of drill down to
and see if there are opportunities to
reduce the cost even more this is such a
young program
um and in standing things up you know i
think i think it costs a little more in
those
initial you know four five six months so
i think
um that'll be we'll be able to be much
more accurate
um in this next year but you know you
know as it stands now we're looking at
you know really cutting in half what it
costs
to take care of these folks you know
compared to if they were in new
hampshire hospital
roughly it's a brilliant initiative
thank you so representative walner do
you have a question
no i just needed to lower my hand i'm
sorry
so so this is the slide again that we're
asked to you know show what would happen
with an
increase or a decrease um let me devil's
advocate you on this first one
sure so so this path model is brilliant
it's it's helping us uh cut costs
um so if we were to replicate it why
wouldn't the money
already be there in the new hampshire
hospital budget to
to because this is a cheaper model why
would this be
i guess i don't understand the question
right i can i can cover it
it would still be an increase to the
total budget because we still need the
total number of beds at new hampshire
hospital
so we're not decreasing beds at the
hospital as much as we're
decreasing the burden around the
inflow and outflow of the hospital
all right i understand
and as far as the decrease where you
know there's this five percent
i just to explain that a little bit more
um where we wrote that we would decrease
capacity
i think it's important because it's so
small um
of a unit and it that staffing is so
small and already so lean
um that it is just right sized as it is
um so you know a decrease in staffing
would represent
us you know definitely um not being able
to take care of as many people over
there
so without making any promises without
making any promises the way i look at
this path centers is a
it's a it's a great innovation
experiment
that should be allowed to proceed
because if you're showing us
a way forward where we can deal with
these other problems at a significantly
lower cost then that's that's brilliant
that's what we need so i
thank you i don't i wouldn't want to
come after this
thank you very much we're excited about
this project it's been
um just a great great challenge and to
see it pay off as it has
you know with discharges is uh it's
pretty
powerful i think so
this speaks to again just the number of
positions this center employs 35
uh staff across three shifts seven days
a week
essentially they're all direct care
how many of those are actual rns and our
rns the most senior level of nursing
care that you have on site
yeah we have um two full-time rns and i
think a part-time
rn those are really the only nursing
staff that we have
then we have a compliment of mental
health workers um
that are there direct care and and again
helping doing you know therapeutic
groups
not the mental health workers no but the
remainder at least half of the staff
that are over there are masters level
social workers
and um case managers and housing
specialists it's a very
so someday not now that it'd be
interesting just to see
um sort of the diversified staff that
you've done it's kind of the
multi-disciplinary approach that you've
used to build that
sure not urgent just in months
for coming yeah so really the staffing
model
uh so joe do you want to talk about this
budget comparison
sure so um in the current biennium as we
mentioned earlier this is really
created through an appropriation from
house bill 4
so we use 2.7 million dollars to create
the program in the current biennium
and the future biennium we are we do
anticipate
earning some revenue so quite frankly we
anticipate earning some revenue in the
current biennium as well um we've just
uh we're working through some systems
issues with that but
um but we can bill for a per diem rate
for transitional housing we will receive
the an in-kind payment for that so
essentially the
the federal share we won't make medicaid
pay us state dollars because we're all
so we do anticipate being able to earn
some revenue there um and then we will
be charging uh residents uh
some rent uh and we're working on
developing that program
um and uh we didn't do it out of the
gate initially um but
we're pretty close to implementing that
practice and the the intent is to have
it be cheaper
obviously than the cost of care at the
hospital
but also kind of reflect that we are
providing a housing service and so
we anticipate charging some rents to
patients as well
i think there's also the psychological
that people value things that they have
to pay for
themselves you know so they
get more buy-in i would imagine if they
actually have to buy
in sure yeah
absolutely i mean that's i think a
critical point for us and that
this is a step down um patients they
have the opportunity
and they should you know as able pay
rent
but also um incentivizing them to find
their own housing too
right i mean this is not long-term um
free
housing this is something that is a
process that the patient's going to work
through
and i just want to also add to that 7.1
million
dollar general fund amount that's
incorrect um i need to
to revisit that but the total cost of
the program uh
is just shy of uh in the 2022-23
biennium is just shy of four million
dollars i think it's 3.8 million
so i will i will revise that and get a
an updated copy for you
and again these are the this is the
accounting unit that's listed
okay are we ready for the briefing book
the budget briefing book
and that's the conclusion of the
presentation on the path
program on my end i don't know if you
need to open something joe i can stop
sharing
so let's see so here is the budget book
it's page
1144. it is the first accounting unit
within
agency 94 and i'm happy that activity
number
oh i'm sorry yeah accounting unit
correct
i see it listed as community residents
yep when we created the accounting unit
we didn't know we were going to name the
um so uh pretty similar to
to other uh slides you know the majority
of this this cost
is uh relative to staffing and payroll
uh in the 2021 biennium we did have some
one-time costs that we
um have excluded from our budget request
moving forward so those were things like
you know our initial purchase of
furniture um
the renovations to the building um
so we did reduce those budget lines you
can see uh as an example class 48
um you know we had 193 000
budgeted for for that and moving forward
it's gonna be
um you know closer to twenty six
thousand so um we've pulled out those
one time costs
um and really the rest of the majority
of the cost here is relative to staffing
um
and yeah i'm happy to take
any questions okay
are there any questions from the
committee
uh representative weiler
thank you mr chair i'm looking at heat
electricity
and water and i'm thinking this is you
know something like the size of a home
uh maybe twice the size of a home and
those those uh
eat electricity and water 100 and some
thousand seems awfully high
for just providing those two
so i apologize i didn't mean to cut you
off
um so that value represents the cost of
so it is a 16 bed program um but
uh but the entire building is um is
is kind of um operated by new hampshire
hospital now or
our kind of collective entity um
so and that number i believe was
provided to us
so i i don't beat you up on your average
that 750
average but if you take that annual cost
of
water and electricity and divide it by
divided into that that seems to me like
that would challenge your 750 number
you know what i'm saying it's it's just
a lot of money
uh and i i don't know how you get a 750
dollar per
patient is that per patient per day or
per patient
per patient per day
all right so i'm off in my head by an
order of magnitude it's okay
any other oh i'm sorry representative uh
uh
walnut you had your hand up yes and
this is just kind of a simple one i'm
sure you haven't
there's an explanation for it so i'm
looking in
um 2021
and under um line 60
benefits you have a half a million
dollars
but yet i don't think we had any
personnel i don't
so how would we pay what were we paying
benefits on
sure so great question um and there's
actually two points i'd like to make
there so to answer your question
directly
these positions because they were
created outside of the budgeting process
are considered eight t positions and so
they show up in that class 50
line there so you can see that there's a
million dollars worth of payroll in
class 50.
those are technically full-time
positions but they're they're temporary
until
they're approved in a budgeting cycle
so so there's that and then i also want
to just mention the difference between
class 60 for 21 and 22
is is that 21 is not an entire year
so so that budget does not represent a a
full year's worth of cost
per se thank you yep
thank you very much mr chair um so
you said 750 is the per day
cost per client what is the per day cost
at the state hospital uh it is
um i believe in the upcoming biennium
uh and then your hand is still up
representative nordran
uh and now representative weiler your
hand is back up sir
yes i'm looking at um benefits paying a
million and a half
pay for the 35 people and then a million
to benefit so it's like
you know 60 percent of the
cost of an employee again in benefits
seems
awfully high but i know we're very
generous in our benefits but that's
still
those numbers are set by the department
of administrative services
we we have no control over the benefits
number so
so sorry i i think we've seen that in
other departments at 60 percent
ratio i think that's just one we've got
to talk to das because that's one of the
big figures that goes across the whole
state we've got to try to find out why
those benefits
are so high i know some of it's the
retirement system has
done a lousy job of investing and so has
the
self-insured done a lousy job of getting
the third party
administrator those are things we've got
to look at as a big picture for the
whole budget
thank you all right
so um are there any other questions from
the committee on
so i'm not seeing any let's uh let's
give
the public an opportunity if uh somebody
on the attendee list wants to raise
their hand to
add some useful knowledge for us
or to make a salient point we'd be
so so there's one by mr norton
mr chairman it was just that last time i
neglected to introduce
myself appropriately i'm ken norton i'm
the executive director for nami new
hampshire
the national alliance on mental illness
and i am registered as a lobbyist on
behalf of nami new hampshire
thank you for correcting that i think
it's just important that we know you're
you're obviously a well-respected
individual
but it's good to know um that you're a
lobbyist thank you
you have anything else to add on this
part i i mean i really commend the
commissioner and
uh heather and her team i think that
there was a lot of
forethought we would be in serious
trouble with emergency department
boarding for adults without the path
program it's definitely helped
alleviate that in a big way what do you
think about the potential for
replication are we going to run in
into the same manpower problems when we
try to get out to the
lakes region um it continues to be an
issue for sure
um but i you know again i think that um
having some ability to look at
credentialing standards and
you know well-trained and
well-supervised staff
that aren't necessarily licensed folks
can be a big help
ms mcquinn i think you're going to say
something mcgowan i
i'm so sorry i'm horrible with names i
got heather but i'm trying to be more
formal you know i used to be a smith and
it was a lot easier back then but it's
heather moquin and uh no i was just
going to echo what
what ken was saying i think we have to
get really creative
um throughout the state around these
workforce issues
um that that really needs some serious
attention
so i just want to throw a crazy idea out
at you
and that would be uh internal
virtualization of the operation
meaning the exploitation of
commercial off-the-shelf technologies to
provide
cameras and audio and so that maybe some
of the
supervision of the of the wings could be
done remotely without having
on-site on and present people
just a crazy idea from an old
telemedicine guy
all right so um
not seeing any more questions or
comments from the attendees
i i think we should probably take a
lunch break here we got two more areas
i'd still like to finish at three
uh last time we broke for 45 minutes or
is there anyone thinking that was too
much time oh wait a second
representative waller go ahead
well i'm sorry i so in in house bill 2
which i are we going to get the form are
we going to get the final uh
i think our expectation is that we're
going to get it today
um but obviously i'm not positive about
that
okay well i'm looking at the draft and
so i would just like to know if we're
going to have someone
come forward to do some explanation for
us because
this is around the 60 bed for forensic
psychiatric hospital
that is to be built on new hampshire
hospital grounds
and it isn't only in house bill 2. i
i don't think i have found it in the the
budget
actually so i just wondered if we were
going to have someone come forward
to give us some explanation about that
and where we are
in the planning of that um
karen i i don't know if um you have
anything to add to that i was just going
to say that
um there has been a work group um so
even last year there was some study
around just
potential sites um here on the campus so
there was some work that was done with
that
and there's been um some ongoing
discussions
on the part of das
and commissioner arlinghaus has been
doing some research
and that's that's as far as my knowledge
goes
at this point i don't know karen if you
have anything else
i can just add as far as the
appropriation the appropriation in the
fiscal year 2021 budget was non-lapsing
so that's the appropriation that's
intended to be used as this project
moves forward
and i know that there is an intent on
the governor's part as you can see from
the hb2 language
to move forward and on the department's
part
okay thank you you're welcome
okay i think we're getting ready to go
to lunch
so um i'm proposing about 45 minutes
was that too long or too short were any
committee members
want to offer a counter proposal
30 minutes i'd say i got to be out of
here by three
okay so um let's say that we'll be back
at 1 15.
and until then we'll reset for lunch 1
[Music]
15.
so
mr ripple i see your email about maybe
using wednesday if we need to
i'm i'm kind of optimistic we can finish
today
okay um it just saves
the presenters the scheduling problem of
having to come back sure
no that's fine i do think they're they
may be ready to come back if needed but
so representative irf may zoom
as he's uh literally zooming in his car
representative representative wallner
are not back just yet representative
walner's here but her video won't start
because it says you cannot start because
the host has disabled you
let me try to fix that
you know i didn't tell him to do that oh
no i turned everybody's video off at uh
at lunch
it's probably a good idea
um okay so representative weiler is here
sir would you would you remind me what
your drop dead time is when
when when do when would you like us to
be done
i have a gopher meeting at three
okay and you probably need a few minutes
just to
transition so i have the same this is
mary jane i have the same meeting so
if maybe what ken do you think maybe
like
yeah it'll probably take me a while to
find the link me too that's what i'm
just thinking
okay all right okay well very good
that's her that's our time schedule
let's let's see if it can happen but uh
mr ripple did
allow for us to continue on wednesday if
we need to
so chairman this is heather um i wanted
to introduce todd bickford he's the
nursing home administrator
at glencliff home i'll be
moving through the slides but todd will
be the person presenting
okay
i'm going to turn my video off so i can
chew
heather do you want me to start right
from the beginning or do you want to do
the first three or four slides
um nope you can start from the beginning
that's fine okay
uh is now a good time to start mr
champion
um thank you everyone for allowing me to
uh present in front of you today
this afternoon and i have to say it's
been very interesting watching the first
present
a couple presentations a very similar
setup with our
powerpoint slides here this is our
agenda which is
basically the same as the last couple on
your next slide
you'll see again our contact information
um
you know heather is the ceo of new
hampshire hospital which is also my
direct report and then joe is the cfo
for both glencliff home and new
hampshire hospital
then trying to stick with the moving
fast forward we have our overview and
delivery system
um some brief history for those of you
that are not familiar with glencliff
home
we started in 1909 um actually 1906 is
when the legislation was first passed
but we had our first patients in 1909
um as a tv sanitarium uh because back
then um treatment for tv was fresh
mountain air and sunshine and we are
located on the
side of mount moose lock i'm up here in
the north country
then in the 70s when there was now
treatment for tb
we the legislature at the time decided
to transition us into a
nursing home that specializes in serving
individuals with psychiatric
or developmental disability issues and
actually at that time
it was close to when the state school in
laconia was closing and we've got a fair
number of patients from there
in additional there was a building on
the main campus of dhhs and conquered
their building
which had over three hundred beds very
similar model as uh glencoefizz and at
that time it was
decided to downsize that facility and
relocate a number of people
here to coincliff so
we serve part of the back door as the
term we've been using today
solution from new hampshire hospital we
do have a long wait list which i'll get
to on the
future slides but we take priority from
new hampshire hospital it's actually we
had it
added to law that new hampshire hospital
gets priority for any beds that are
available
all right on the next slide you'll see
where we fit in
again it's demonstrating that we are
part of the discharge
process for new hampshire hospital
pretty straightforward and then our
ultimate goal
is to move people back into the
community as well
which speaks to our mission you know
continuing with service for
development mental and mentally ill
population in a home-like atmosphere an
emphasis on independence dignity
acceptance and i do like to speak here
that
the real key word for our population is
acceptance
our folks have had challenges their
whole lives now they have medical
challenges on top of their mental
illness or
developmental disability and have been
in and out of new hampshire hospital
um in some successful placements in the
communities
often a lot of people come to us where
they've been living in a group home or
living in their own apartment dealing
very well with their
schizophrenia but now they have copd or
they have brittle diabetes and they have
other medical needs
which is just compounded by their mental
illness so they need additional support
our long-term vision uh is basically the
residents will live a full life
and gain independence by overcoming
their challenges and developing the
skills to move back into their preferred
community
and on the next side unless there's
questions sorry for going too fast
i do have a question there on your
previous slide
um and and you've kind of said it twice
about the
the vision um i
okay so in in practical
effect is this really an aspirational
vision
given that my sense of this population
is is there kind of um for lack of a
better word
you know set in their ways they're
they're elderly they have psychiatric
problems
they're probably really not gonna go
back home and and just live a normal
life
or am i wrong uh you're not fully wrong
um we in a future slide you'll see we've
been able to discharge 26
people in the last three years back to
the community or to a group home or to
another nursing home
um but right now i believe we have
26 people actively working on being
discharged back to the community now
that might take a year that might take
two years either for them to develop the
skill sets that they need to be
independent
or for us to find placement because we
have the same challenges if not more
challenging than new hampshire hospital
does
finding housing because all of our folks
need some additional medical help
where we have been successful in
discharging people is to
either group home settings that have
been set up with a medical model
or into home situations um like elder
care so a family agrees to take one of
our residents
into their home and provide services
through that way
it's very specialized to the individual
so that's about 20 percent of our
residents are actively working on going
back into the community
um however a large portion as you say we
are a nursing home
um so you know people are coming to us
with some severe medical challenges on
top of their mental illness
so that does make it challenging for
them to move out and quite honestly
a vast majority of our folks don't want
to go back to the community
they have tried and failed before and
they found a real homeless community
here
so we are required by cms to ask the
residents every three months if they're
interested in moving back to the
community
and typically it's about 20 to 30
percent say yes but the rest are
more than happy to be here and their
families and guardians are also very
happy to have
have them here in a safe structured
situation
so that would imply and i'm not trying
to be morbid
but i just want to understand your
setting that would
that would apply that a very large
percentage
will be discharged into hospice care
or or just uh death
you are correct we do hospice care here
um you know so think of us as a nursing
home um
we're very similar situation as the the
county homes
except for who we serve uh and yes we
refer to it as celestial discharge
when someone passionately say that term
again celestial discharge
when someone passes away this is a nice
way of saying
they died you never heard that term we
made it out here
we're very unique up here in the north
country
uh moving on so again a little more
history
um we are located up north we're 69
miles
northwest of concord um on the side of
mount mooselok and technically we're in
the town of benton but you can't get
there from here
that's why we're called glencliff home
because the closest village is glencliff
which is part of
the town of warren we provide a full
continuum of services like any other
nursing home
including medical social services
pretty much anything that an individual
needs
part of what makes glenn cliff unique is
that we are self-sustaining campus we
are off the grid
that's how we were originally built we
have a water wheel that produces about
30 35 of our electrical power we
actually have a capital project to
double that
and when the water wheel just for an
example of how useful that is when the
water wheel is functioning we save 100
gallons of diesel
from the generators every day which is a
significant savings
we're also working on adding steam
turbines because our campus
is heated using steam heat and we
about eight maybe 10 years ago we
transitioned to a biomass
generation so we burn wood chips to
create all of our heat hot water
and hopefully electricity in the future
and i always love to invite anybody to
come up for a tour
um clients and services again i spoke
briefly about this you know we provide a
full continuum of any nursing home
main focus is on nursing care adult
living care
we do provide recreational services
pre-covert that would include
trips to the community shopping we rent
a house on a lake
once a year so residents can go swimming
and do some barbecues
we provide all the environmental
services such as housekeeping laundry
maintenance dietary we're actually very
well known for our food
most nursing homes have a difficulty
with residents losing weight when
they're admitted we have a difficulty
with residents gaining weight
so that's something that we're
constantly working on with our dietitian
so we do also strive to use as many
non-medication
modalities and alternative approaches as
possible
we have staff trained in things such as
reiki
just peer-to-peer support we do things
like that
just trying to redirect somebody and
again that takes me back to part of our
mission where we accept people for who
they are
in other nursing homes they really
um have a difficulty dealing with
somebody that has a
behavior where they're verbally
disruptive they're screaming or yelling
out
other nursing homes have to um market
themselves and sell themselves and it's
difficult when they're giving a tour and
someone's
acting out we having the benefit of
being
run by the state do not have to market
ourselves
we actually always have a waitlist as
you'll see in a future slide
so we end up taking the people that no
one else will
we actually knowing that we're a scarce
resource have required
for the past 15 years that um for when
someone applies to come here they have
to demonstrate in writing that at least
two other nursing home facilities has
rejected them
and turned them down and usually it's
many more than that
again we strive to take people directly
from new hampshire hospital um
in your conversations with natural
hospital you ask about
redirecting people from the e d
instead of going to national hospital we
occasionally are able to do that with an
elder
um at least a couple times a year it's
not as freaking as we'd like but
um sometimes we can do a direct emit
from one of those situations
to help relieve that situation all right
on the next slide
is a picture of our staff um
i think it speaks to the dedication of
my staff um
similar to what heather was talking
about when they have a hospital i've
been here
20 years um hoping to be here for
another 10 um before i can retire with
the state
um a large number of my employees have
been here
um for quite a long time including the
direct care staff
this last year or two has been
challenging a
greater percentage of our folks now fall
into one to five years
but i about 60 percent of our staff are
still in the
five years plus range
all right the next slide there's a nice
aerial
shot um of the facility
so we maintain about 70 acres now back
in the history we had over 500 acres and
we did our own farming
had cattle and pigs and those kind of
things back in the tv days but now we
just maintain
a much smaller campus but that includes
again the power plant
a laundry facility some out housings
that used to be like the head herdsmen's
house but that we now use to house
traveling nurses
maintenance shops and then the main
large building that you can see there is
the resident areas
and then the other buildings are used
for administration and training and
thank you moving on to our key
performers
so our census um
the difference here that you'll notice
between what we
budget for in our actual ability billing
monthly census is really largely due
in the past to billable days so as a
normal nursing home
we bill at midnight so if we have a
resident that for some reason needs to
go to cottage hospital or our local
hospital
for three days we can't bill for those
three days
so even though they're technically in a
bed and we have we cannot fill that bed
uh we're required by cms to hold the bed
for a certain length of time
we can't bill for it um so that drops
our averages
um ideally we get up to 118
um filled beds so that our averages will
fall back closer to 116.
um but i can tell you this last year has
been very challenging not only to
the obvious scope of 19 challenges that
every nursing home has faced in the
state
um but also with staffing issues
any questions so far well i was just
going to ask
um looking at that aerial photo
is there is there room to grow
have you have you ever do you have any
on on the shelf
plans to uh build more
um actually that is a great question and
i am thrilled that you asked me
so if you're looking at the picture uh
inside the horseshoe of the large
building
we actually got um not last not this
biennium but last biennium we got a
capital project to fund
the design and blueprints to be
of a specific dementia unit we'd be
right now we have four units we would be
building in that
ground we would actually sink it down
into the ground and it would have a live
roof so all of those windows would look
out over this new building
and we would add 26 beds specifically
designed for dementia patients
because as i'll talk about shortly one
of our challenges
is that over the last particularly 10
years
more and more of our folks have
developed dementia here
and more and more people on our wait
list have dementia so now you're talking
about somebody that has
a nursing home level medical issue
someone that has a mental illness or a
developmental disability and on top of
that and are now developing
dementia which is particularly
challenging for us because
the techniques and strategies that you
use with somebody
um that's suffering from a a mental
illness
and having those kind of behaviors um
don't always work with somebody with
uh that has developed dementia and what
we're seeing happen is someone who has
developed skills to
ignore the voices in their heads per se
now they've got dementia and they've
lost those skills
um so their mental illness gets
exasperated by the dementia
on top of the challenge of a dementia
that anybody would have
probably more than yeah do you have uh
do you have an exterior fence to keep
dementia patients from wanting yes you
can't see it in this picture but
right on that tree line so that's a fire
break that goes around the whole campus
in just inside the tree line there is a
fence um
all the way down to that road for the
very specific person that if we did have
somebody that was a flight risk or a
wander risk
get out unsupervised it would funnel
them down towards the maintenance shops
and the main roads so that
more staff would have a chance to find
them knock on wood
and i'm not trying to curse myself but
my 20 years we've only had
one incidence where a resident was
missing and um
we put in our plan which involves the
state police and dogs um
even before the dogs got here staff
found them um he had climbed over the
fence um he was more physically able he
climbed over the fence but we found him
thank god so that's the only instance of
that
all right so i think we were on slide
14.
this is our wait list um typically
we've been between 20 and 30 but you'll
see
a huge increase starting when
pandemic started we found an increase on
people that couldn't get into other
facilities because of the challenges
we have difficulty discharging people to
the community
um because of other challenges those
challenges and
um our staffing has really been
suffering this last year so there has
been periods of time where we have froze
our census
um because we just don't have the staff
to take care of a full complement of
residents
so right now we have 44 people 14 of
them are at new hampshire hospital
key accomplishments and i'm extremely
extremely proud of my staff for this
first one
we have remained coveted free throughout
the whole pandemic
we have been extremely fortunate i think
this is one of those cases where
being in a remote location has helped us
where it hurts us with recruitment it
certainly helps with pandemic
well my staff deserves a huge credit
they've done an excellent job
of doing all the things that cms
requires above and beyond
screening taking care of things like
that and at this point we have 93
of our residents have been fully
vaccinated and the seven percent uh is
because they chose not to
um that was an individual's choice um to
be vaccinated or not
um so we're very proud of that one uh
second accomplishment we implemented um
back in 2017 really
doing an l a class because we are
really hurting for staffing so we've
realized that we need to grow our own
so we have in the last year and a half
or so graduated 28 lnas and three m
a's and m a is a medication nursing
assistant so it's an illness that has an
additional certification
so they can pass medications they can't
assess
or diagnose but they can pass
medications and then if they see a
resident that might be having an issue
they can go and get a nurse so that that
has helped
with our staffing somewhat and then as i
mentioned earlier
since 2017 we have discharged 26
residents back out in the community
again this helps us admit patients from
new hampshire hospital and other
other facilities really you know part of
the back door solution
key accomplishments uh we are an old
campus a lot of old buildings you
referenced earlier today you know a
building that must have looked great in
1880s well
some of our buildings looked great in
1806 in 1809
and now they need a lot of work um we
have gotten some capital projects in the
last few bienniums
the last one being improving our pothole
water system
historically the facility has used a
basically a dug well
up on the side of the mountain
established in
1940 it's a 30 foot round 30 foot deep
dug well
it provided all the water up until the
last couple years where we have had to
add some additional artesian wells
and we're looking actually to remove the
dug well offline with a couple
more wells as recommended by des
and then things like improving the fire
access road and roof and boilers and
generators and all those kind of fun
things
key challenges front door for us
uh obviously a wait list of 44 is not
acceptable that means
a large number of people are waiting to
get into the facility
for us they are mostly not not in eds
occasionally they are most of them are
either still at home
at a hospital but admitted but they're
looking to play some or at new hampshire
hospital
and that is the our biggest customer is
new hampshire hospital
so and then as i mentioned before the
significant increase in referrals with
patients with dementia
um so dementia itself is not a diagnosis
that will allow somebody to come here
but like i said they often are paired
with someone that has medical issues on
top of a mental illness and now have
dementia on top of that
our backdoor issue is uh as you've heard
a couple of times today
housing in the community and support
systems in the community
because our folks not only have to have
the supports around their mental illness
they also need to have the supports
around
their medical needs diabetes being a
great example
someone might mentally and cognitively
be
very capable of living in a group home
but most group homes do not have a nurse
available to do injections
and to do insulin and these individuals
are not able to do them themselves
very much related to that is the support
support staff in the community
operational our real big one is
recruitment and retention
you know the hospital spoke about a
number of um initiatives that they've
taken we've taken some similar ones
but we are uh really struggling
particularly because of our location
um you know those 28 people that we've
put through our
lna program we've off like we just
offered a program to start in february
and we had nobody
apply we've kind of tapped all of the
resources around us so we're starting to
expand that circle we're advertising
further out
and basically it's grow your own so if
someone agrees to take the class
and be an lna with us for a year it's
free for them
so initially we had a number of
employees that came from other
departments such as
dietary and housekeeping in laundry that
took the class
and became lnas and then we had a number
of people from the community
unfortunately not all of them have
stayed with us
after their initial commitment and then
we have the typical um
challenges of operationing a a 100 plus
year old campus
furniture equipment buildings those type
lots of benchmarks and staffing
if we were to get at five percent i'm
sorry
yeah would you would you give me a call
after this i i have a crazy
an idea too crazy to say in public
okay i want to share i want to share an
idea with you okay i will certainly get
like today
that'd be great okay i will do that
so if we were to get an increase we
would put that towards
additional professional recruitment of
staff
we have been using some travel nurses we
have talked with new hampshire hospital
about increasing some of those
contracts and how much we pay for nurses
but also
number of contracts the covid
has really hurt us there pre-covered we
were using
three to five travel nurses at a time
uh we have two right now um and we're
lucky to have them
um a lot of places like florida we're
offering huge sign-on bonuses and things
like that for travel nurses
that we were just obviously not able to
compete with
then we would put more money into
improving resident living areas
and then facility maintenance and
equipment upgrade if we were to get a
additional cuts obviously we would have
to take that out of staffing about
83 percent of our budget is personnel
um joe can correct me if i'm wrong on
that number
um so unfortunately we would have to
eliminate
vacancies first for savings
but a lot of that vacancy money we are
now using to pay the agency nurses
and to pay for overtime so we're
maintaining
safe staffing levels but that is heavy
use of overtime
and travel nurses and then we would you
know
do the typical defer equipment and
maintenance
so this next slide speaks to our
staffing challenges
um and uh you know obviously the first
line is our nurses
drs is just another term for director of
nursing
so we have 31 nurses in total that
includes
five nursing managers um but please
don't think of them as administration
they work the floors um even our
director of nursing we're at the point
where she's working
um you know eight 12 hours 16 hours out
of her 40 hours a week
direct care giving medications and
providing care to the residents
because we are so low low staff that
number is actually a little deceiving
38 vacancy rate for nurses it's a little
higher because we have an individual out
on fnla
but when you break it out by shift our
second
shift nursing is at 62 percent vacancy
rate
um so you know that requires us to have
nurses from day shift or third shift
move on
do overtime cover shifts we are
the last year and a half first time ever
mandating nurses we never had to in my
20 plus years until this last year and a
half so um so we are really struggling
with nurses
same can be said with lnas not quite as
severe you know the overall vacancy rate
is about 20 to 23
but if you look at um third shift um
lnas we're at like 40
vacancy and second shift is about 35
percent
uh we obviously do better on day shifts
because people like to work during the
day
instead of nights and uh and on the
weekends so
other than that um we do usually pretty
well with recruiting
um you know we have some vacancies some
of the other departments which is a new
thing for us and i think it is somewhat
co-related
we never even used to have to advertise
for positions other than nurses and l
a's and this year we're finding that we
do have to advertise and put some more
effort into finding people that are
looking for
state jobs questions if you have an
on-call
sleeping facility there so that if
somebody is working overtime they could
go crash for a few hours so we do have
um
there's a couple of houses on campus
that i mentioned earlier uh we use one
for travel nurses so the other one is
available for nurses like
uh a couple weeks ago when we had one of
those bad storms we had a nurse that was
working second shift
he asked if he could sleep over because
then he was gonna work first shift and
second shift he's gonna do a double the
next day
so we do things like that routinely um
and then we also use them for the travel
nurses so there is some of that
and then um due to our nursing shortages
the director of nursing and the nurse
on-call duties for the weekends so that
if a nurse calls out sick
one of those nurses gets called in
we're really burning out our staff so
that's why
excuse me that's why we have frozen
admissions um
and off and on representative walter has
thank you did um
the staff at the uh at glencliff
also get the 20 pay enhancement that was
um provided for new hampshire hospital
oh no they did not uh
new hampshire hospital went forward they
were also at a critical staffing
for 20 for mental health workers my
staff
are lnas so they were not included in
that
that is something we are looking at
potentially asking government councils
for
but we haven't at this point so it's not
hello no thank you
representative weiler
uh thank you mr chair uh i see all those
buildings on that campus
does any of the staff live on campus
just the travel nurses they're the only
ones
it seems like you what what kind of
commute do most of them have you're
fairly remote
how's the longest road you've got to get
to your facility
well my deputy administrator lives in
concord
um so she travels an hour and 15 good
weather
i'd say the average employee is probably
30 minutes um
you know we have someone live right here
in warren so they're 15 20 minutes
um but then we have people that come all
the way down from littleton
lisbon we have a number of staff that
live in vermont so i'd say on
average 30 to 40 minutes um
so i was wondering if you had a
dormitory if you would help in
recruiting and you could charge a little
bit for the
for living there and be a good deal for
some people that they work right on
campus
you're starting to get into my crazy
idea there representative weiler ah
sorry
well no why not partner with a community
college
erected dormitory and
use the patients that are there is the
basis for
the the training opportunities
and then try to produce enough clinical
staff
to take care of your own during training
and still have others available
around the state turn it into a small
college campus
all we need is money actually
all we need is trained personnel to be
teachers um
we it's not an off the wall idea we have
been working with the vermont technical
college because they're they're close to
us over the border
for the last two years trying to
establish a
lpn program a licensed practical nurse
program here on campus we have a
building
we bought most of the equipment we would
need we've done
most of the paperwork with the new
hampshire board of nursing where we have
failed
is for the college or ourselves to
recruit a nurse with enough credentials
to teach it
most nurses that have their masters are
higher
are working already in the teaching
field or they're working at hospitals
and things like that as teachers
significant salaries so we have not been
able
we we had one we thought we were on the
verge of opening
our first class since last august but
she declined the position
at last minute the deal with vermont
technical college was
they provide all of the credentialing
they provide some of the supports
we provide the instructor and we get
four
free slots so we can put four of our
employees into their
program for free by providing the
instructor and we've not been able to
recruit somebody
so it's not an off the wall idea we do
partner with um
plymouth state university they use us as
a clinical for
their nursing program so we have
students coming through regularly
unfortunately we don't
ever really get any of those nurses
because they're young
and they want to work in hospitals and
they want to work in mid-surge they want
to work in er
they don't typically want to do nursing
home level care
some of them have shown some interest
this year so i'm hoping maybe we'll get
one or two because they're more
interested in the site part of it
um so we pre exhaustively try
um including every time i go get blood i
hand out my business card
um any nurses is more than welcome
representative nordgren you have a
question
yeah yes thank you
um i'm worried looking at this slide
that you're really lacking custodial
care
um with the pandemic and all the
concerns we have now this
must be really hard for you to keep up
all right it certainly has been
challenging um and we have a couple of
vacancies so it's not a large department
beginning with there's only nine
positions so
um right now we have two vacant um but
we do have somebody in the pipeline
i believe they're starting in two weeks
so that number will go down
but really all of the staff have stepped
up um
so l a's in particular also do cleaning
especially like the typical wiping down
door handles and
hand rails and those type of things but
even maintenance has stepped up and
done some additional housekeeping work
um in some of the technologies that
joe mentioned earlier we bought one of
the ultraviolet robots that can clean a
room
so we've been learning how to do it more
efficiently
in more uh more specifically to the
pandemic concerns uh so they've been
doing a nice job
um but it really is a team effort up
here so
uh right now we're hurting a little bit
and particularly on second shift of
housekeeping but i think we've got
comments or questions on this slide so
continuing with uh benchmarking
so this is a slide that gives you a it's
a point in time
this is the national average the state
average and then our average for
staffing
and they break it down it's just looking
at nursing
and specifically rn and then lna
this information is gathered by cms's
survey so
as any other nursing home in the state
we are
under cms regulations so once a year we
have a survey team from the bureau of
health and facilities
which is also part of dhhs come and do a
full survey
they take a two week picture of our
staffing
and use it to compare it to everybody
else so while this
looks like we're doing well we're
average
it's actually a little low for us
because typically because of our
population we want to staff a little
um higher than most nursing homes um and
this was a point in time about a year
ago i think right now so if you add the
43 minutes the 2 hours and
35 minutes you get about an hour
uh 3.2 we've been averaging about
2.8 or 3.0 um
the last couple of months um but we're
hope we're working hard
to bump that back up we maintain it
again using overtime
travel nurses and then mandating staff
when we have to but
as you can expect nobody likes to be
mandated
so we try not to do that as much as
possible
oh i guess this is the part where i turn
it back over to joe
um sure thank you everyone
thank you uh so from a financial
perspective
uh glencliff is is pretty evenly split
between general funds and other funds
their other fund source is really
medicaid revenue
um so uh uh a
virtually an overwhelming majority
if not all of the patients at glencliff
um qualify for medicaid
um and they receive a daily rate
uh as a nursing home uh so
this is really their their source of
funds um they don't have
uh much of an opportunity to bill uh
other insurances they they do bill
uh patients or estates directly um
if if uh the opportunity arises but it's
not very common
most of these individuals are are really
a
primary uh medicaid patient population
if i can inject we currently have two
um so so their general funds are pretty
uh
consistent year over year um and then
the
the total funds of their budget um
you'll see from the 2020 2021 bienniums
to the 2022 biennium not a significant
increase in uh in total funds
and uh there were a few prioritized
needs that were created for a glencliff
it's it was mostly relative to
wages due to vacancies so um
we do have a list of prioritized needs
and i can provide that if if the
community
if the committee is interested in seeing
[Music]
and did you want me to go on to the um
the budget book now or let's see that
yes
okay okay shut off
sure not seeing any questions so so
let's keep rolling
so glencliff in the budget book starts
at page 1099
it is activity code 9100 and their first
accounting unit is
5710.
this first accounting unit is for
professional care this is
primarily all of their direct care staff
and the costs associated with providing
[Music]
again we had some prioritized needs that
we created for
predominantly payroll lines so you'll
see class 18 in this
is is pretty flat
[Music]
happy to take any questions
uh representative walner thank you
um did you is is this pretty much what
you requested
of the governor and are the prioritized
needs
that you had um that you gave to the
governor that were not funded
um so great question the prioritized
needs were not funded in the
governor's phase i can
i i heard this question come up on a few
prior presentations that i tuned in on
uh
and so i can certainly provide uh what
those were
they are included on the total
prioritized needs spreadsheet
um that i provided to kevin last week
so you should have those on that
spreadsheet
okay um i just went further why
i unfortunately haven't looked at that
um yet
and um could you just quickly
maybe highlight the top you know the the
most important prioritized needs that
you had on your list
sure um todd please jump in at any point
but i
i think um really any of the payroll
lines relative to this accounting unit
5710 direct care
um i would i would say are the most
important
and would you agree with that todd
[Music]
yes
uh so those were um class 18 uh class
50 part-time staff um
and i'm trying to remember the others
that were in this accounting unit
i saw that some of it because it's um
payroll spills into um bumping up the
benefits
um and it's about 500 000
total and 400 of that is personnel
related
the other 100 000 is a few things like
equipment
i think representative has more
questions no thank you
that's helpful representative
weiler
all right thank you um consultants
consultants
uh would you like me to answer that joe
sure uh so on that line
46 um we have a dentist that comes well
came pre-covered um twice a month now he
comes only on urgent care
we also pay a high hygienist out of that
because we do have a full
dental suite here at the facility we
have a registered dietitian
that i believe is paid out of that line
we have a
podiatrist rn that comes and provides
those services
uh and then i think we might also have a
massage therapist in there
thank you you have a pastor do you have
pastoral services
uh we do we have a
again pre-coveted we have a roman
catholic priest that comes and does
mass on sundays and then we have a
protestant minister that also comes and
then we have
a couple of different bible groups that
come regularly again pre-coping
right now nobody comes in did any of
those
uh come under this consulting line or
were they volunteer
because that doesn't seem like a lot of
money for all that extra
ancillary care you're getting well most
of that ancillary care
is pretty infrequent like i said the
dentist only comes twice a month
um and i might be off a little bit like
the
dietitian who has a bigger contract she
might be out of um
101 medical payments
but medical payments is also where we've
been using to you'll see that number's
awfully large
we've been using that for the travel
nurses
you have a follow-up representative or
was that
okay uh just moving along
so uh 5720 custodial care
i'm a little slow i want to go back for
a second
so so you knew how much ancillary care
you wanted and it was all working and
then the pandemic hit and they've
essentially stopped coming so so what is
the clinical outcome
what what what is the suffering as a
result
of the diminished care is it
measurable in any way or is it just
subjective
uh mostly subjective but it is
measurable in that um
we've had times where we've had to
freeze our admissions um
so that hurts the wait list that hurts
new hampshire hospital that hurts our
revenue
so that's one um very uh
measurable outcome um as far as direct
care for our residents um
hopefully uh they have not been to our
knowledge they have not been suffering
medically
um because we continue to use over time
and mandating to ensure that they're
getting the care they need
now socially and mentally they're
certainly suffering this year
because of the pandemic so you know our
residents we have four units they've
been um confined to their own right
their own unit you know they have
friends in other units they can't go
outside unsupervised so
a lot of that's happened and they can't
go on shopping trips and outlook
to dinner and things like that that we
used to do um pre-covet so that has
certainly affected it
but the low staffing also affects that
because when we're at minimum staffing
we don't have the extra staff for those
type of activities
um so that's where we suffer the the
recreational the social
you know the cognitive stimulation
suffers
so the the next accounting unit was 5720
uh which is custodial care
this is where the supportive departments
for things like housekeeping
um facilities uh et cetera
that's primarily what constitutes this
accounting unit
the cost of that staff
food and nutrition
[Music]
again there were some prioritized needs
relative to payroll lines
in this accounting unit as well but uh
again if we were to prioritize them we
would prioritize the
prioritized needs in the 5710 accounting
unit over the 5720
accounting unit so is that contracted
food services
if so is that done on site or off-site
and brought in
uh is not contracted they are state
employees and we do it all on site
um we have our own dietary department
we looked at it i wanna say five years
ago
maybe six years ago um and actually
the cost of contracting it um
was within ten thousand dollars of what
we pay for it here
um back then i'm sure it's changed in
five six years
so at that time the decision was made to
continue to leave them as state
employees
any questions on this accounting unit
okay uh the next one is accounting unit
this is the uh administrative accounting
unit
again they run a very lean
administrative shop at glencliff very
and this really comprises of their their
core leadership structure
is that telecommunications for the whole
operation
or is there telecommunications
throughout
um i i believe that is for the whole
facility because
we pay for a phone that is
that is correct it is for the whole
facility um so
um our internet and um computer and
stuff comes through the department
you have clients or patients that
want to use um the wi-fi for their own
internet access
yes and that's something we actually are
continuing to work with
doit on when the pandemic hit we had
no wi-fi in the facility we didn't even
have it for our nurses
it's something we've been struggling
with to get
up here on the hill with the oit's
approval
when pandemic hit they were able to
install
nine laptops with zoom on it so that
residents could contact their families
and do some telehealth but it is
extremely limited it can only do zoom
literally the computers are locked down
that they can only do zoom and we can't
initiate them we can only accept them
so i'm still working with doit to
provide
some wi-fi for the residents because
they are
really desperate for that kind of
information access
so just to share a story the veterans
home um
has their clients all contract
separately for wi-fi services internet
access and uh there's been a number of
complaints originating from the veterans
saying that
they get really bad wi-fi service
because of all of the contention
in the and competing for the limited
wi-fi
there so i think d.o.t had a solution
doit had a solution for the veterans
home
but um but the commandant
has other reasons not to do it but so
so i i just hope that you know given the
pandemic and all the social isolation
we're finding
ways to to to let our patients
interact with the outside world and it
sounds like that's a priority to you too
absolutely we actually just um last
thursday
received a set cell phone booster
that we can put on our roof because we
also don't have cell phones up here
um we have no reception um so that's
even more limiting so we're trying
everything we can
wow going back to the 1950s
i also just want to add to we've been
researching some
potential grant funding opportunities to
try to bring um
tele teleconferencing video conferencing
type equipment
tickling cliff for both educational and
uh patient
patient uh uses so are you working with
dartmouth to do that
because they they access a lot of grants
or one how are you never mind just let's
let's keep going i'm sorry
i still want to try to finish in 45
minutes if possible
uh so the last primary accounting unit
for glencliff is their maintenance
accounting unit
um uh again there were some prioritized
needs in here relative to payroll
and uh really the rest of the accounting
unit remains
[Music]
okay the rest of glencliff's accounting
units are really
um relative to things like capital
projects
or um um unemployment
really things that we don't have a a
whole lot of control over so
so that's really for glencliff
[Music]
do you have any big hb2 things we need
not to my knowledge i haven't seen
anything relatives have gone close
[Music]
here i'm gonna i'm gonna skip over the
uh
attendees for a while just because i we
have some legislators that need to cut
out
so so i'm not seeing any questions from
the panelists let's let's go on to the
next presentation and thank you
thank you very much thank you for your
attention and your thoughtful questions
we really appreciate it
we have a couple of follow-up items and
we'll get those to you
um would you still like me to call you
rebellion no you heard my crazy idea
already
the surprise is over we can talk about
that some other day
all right thank you thanks heather
thanks todd thanks joe
take care so
up next is the division uh for
behavioral health
uh which the director of that is katya
fox
and i believe kevin is in process of
this division comprises of three
separate bureaus
so i don't believe we will finish this
okay so i've heard miss fox before and
she does a great job
um why don't you think about giving us
30 minutes and then we'll have to carry
great um so just making sure everyone
can hear me if i could get a thumbs up
on that
all right um so good afternoon
my name is katya fox i'm the director
for the division for behavioral health
and i have a team behind me that is
ready willing and able to step in and
answer questions
as they arise given the fact that we
only have 30 minutes
i think what we'll do is we'll try to
get through
one of the bureaus but i'm not sure if
that's going to be possible based on the
questions that you have
and the enormity of the division in the
division's work
so jane jackson is our finance director
and she reports directly to karen
and i am in my office in concord
if that matters to anyone so
what i want to do is just talk a little
bit so this is the agenda you've seen
this
now several times um the
division so the overview it's was
created
five years ago and the idea was to bring
together
behavioral health services and supports
at the community level
so this morning you heard from new
hampshire hospital which is at the acute
psychiatric level and then you just
heard from going cliff which is more the
long-term
uh services that are are needed in this
system
and so we're really focused on the
community-based systems
and that includes um there's no vision
or mission statement here
however our driving forces right now
are all about systems transformation
so in the middle of a pandemic we're
trans trying to transform
our systems to better address the needs
of individuals and families
who are struggling with behavioral
health issues
so we have the bureau of drug and
alcohol services and i'm going to give
you a little buzzwords as a way to
cue you so that you know when you hear
something in the news you know what
how it relates to this presentation so
for example
opioid overdoses and opioid deaths
that's
what you would commonly think about when
you hear about the drug
and alcohol services bureau
they are working very hard we are all
working very hard
on a action plan um that was developed
it's a two-year action plan that ends at
the
end of this calendar year and it really
focuses
on addressing the need to reduce
the incidence of deaths and
the misuse of alcohol and other drugs
for children's behavioral health you had
a lot of conversation about that this
morning
that is also undergoing a significant
systems transformation
and that is um really known and governed
by
the system of care another buzzword that
you hear about
and we're going to go into more details
about that
and then the 10-year mental health plan
so that encompasses both children and
adults
and that is governing a lot of the work
that we do
and most importantly for this
particular committee it is where
a lot of our funding is directed
so you're going to see some growth in
funding and that's because the need is
so great
and the opportunity is really standing
before us
to continue to transform the system we
don't want to just keep adding services
and nibbling at the edges
we want to rethink of everything that we
do
so that we're not just expecting um to
add
and add an ad to a system that's already
stressed
we want to transform that system and
have it be
so the first unit you'll see is the
behavioral health policy unit
there are six of us um in this
particular
area and it's division wide and
this is really the area that provides
technical assistance
to not only um within the department
and within our division but also with
stakeholders so a lot of this
work in these positions are focused
on grant writing and
medicaid policy we've had the
you'll be hearing more about in the
medicaid presentation
about what you probably are aware of
which is the integrated delivery
networks in the 1115
transformation waiver um that has been
going on for five years
and there also is legislative work
um so we have a
person who's dedicated to being our
legislative liaison
and working with all of you on important
initiatives
so here is this is just within the
division this isn't the entire division
including all the bureaus
this is just in this um accounting
section and again you'll see some growth
there
and if you have specific questions jane
jackson
can answer them but what you'll see
is that those federal funds are part of
a
interagency transfer that actually
directly relate to new hampshire
hospital and to
glencliff home so you'll see
where those funds are for medicaid
payments that go to those two facilities
and then the rest of it is the staffing
and
the ancillary required financing for
that
so i i put this slide really early on so
we could cut to the chase about the
prioritized needs
and then we'll go into it um if
necessary
as we get into the various bureaus so
additional guardianship slots um
we have guardianships that are required
under law
and these are typically individuals that
you may think of at new hampshire
hospital
who need assistance and
help in managing their finances for
example
and so a guardian will be appointed by
the court
and i have the numbers um i won't go
over them now
but this would provide for an additional
slots um for that so that was one of our
prioritized needs
that was not funded and
hold on a second you can get 10 slots
funded with 30
000 or an or is 30 000
just the additional amount that you need
that you didn't get
so it's ten new slots for thirty
thousand dollars believe it or not the
rate
is very low because um typically those
guardianship services um aren't
just a surprising amount but um all
right
and then the other prioritized need was
one and a half million dollars for
stabilization
services um as we look at
streamlining and transforming our
emergency
services response and that gets into
representative wallner's comments and i
believe representative norgren talked
about
mobile crisis and was asking about
mobile crisis
so we're transforming the approach that
is currently used
um again not adding services and
expecting more and more and more
but really re-looking at how we provide
those services
and where and so this funding
would have supported that continued
effort
so katya before you jump into the
bureaus if you can just go back one
slide
chair would you like to go over these
four accounting units which are related
to the division as a whole
before we go into the bureau's um and
the bureau information
let's let's go ahead into a bureau
because this sounds like it's
fairly routine
they are pretty straightforward
accounting units okay
all right let's see i was going to ask i
was going to ask
mrs fox which part of dhhs she thinks we
should get that 1.5 million a year but
i would defer to commissioner shibanet
and
cfo rounds on which area should
get those funds um but this is um
so um the bureau of drug and alcohol
services the aforementioned
um so it's a single state substance
misuse authority
which is designated by the federal
government we have to have a single
state authority
for drug and alcohol services and we
also have one for mental health
and so this one is for
for the drug and alcohol services and
this is essentially the
slide that shows the services that are
provided
and so you start with prevention and i
know you're going to be talking a lot
more about prevention
when it comes to public health but also
from
the other the other divisions um
crisis and acute services so we think
about
everyone knows the word detox
and that kind of immobile response which
also
occurs in the um suv arena
outpatient and residential treatment i
think we all know what that is
peer recovery support services very
critical to the work that
everyone does in ongoing recovery
from a substance use disorder and then
family support services which
i know that we've seen ken norton a
couple of times
and know that family supports are
so what a one of those areas entail
and so we have prevention and education
and population level prevention i'm just
gonna go
and look at my cheat sheets these the
information that i'm providing
is also detailed much more in our
briefing book
um so if you have some questions
especially since
we're unlikely to finish um the entire
division today
sorry chair um i don't think it's gonna
happen um
but i um it may give an opportunity for
you to be able to look
in more detail at what i'm presenting
this afternoon a reasonable goal to
finish this bureau
before shutting down for the day
i think it's reasonable and what i want
to do
is get to the questions um rather than
just
prattle on on something that may not be
of interest when you may have specific
questions
um so to the extent that i can
accommodate that
and really go with the flow just let me
know
so population level strategy so that's
really looking
at community mobilization and engagement
promoting healthy behaviors through
social media and through other means
and increasing awareness to about
access and the services that can be
provided
direct prevention which gets a little
bit more detailed
into people who are at risk or may have
already been engaging in substance
misuse
and then and i can give examples of
those if anyone
wants to know what those are and then
when we get into surveillance
this is where you hear i know that it
used to be a lot more common
um that you would see a news story where
there would be
the liquor enforcement would do
those checks and really determine
whether miners were
accessing alcohol through that means
through uh purchase um through whatever
means that may be
so there were those uh checks that um
happen
and also surveillance includes drop
boxes
which we're all familiar with and have
really increased
over time crisis intervention and
treatment
very very self-explanatory
there have been millions of dollars that
have been afforded to the state through
the state
opioid response grant and
we've been deploying those services
through what you know
and we'll get into this a little bit
more as the doorway program with the
nine doorways across the state
we've had treatment services and so this
is
your traditional thinking about
residential treatment which includes say
for example
farnum center or phoenix house
and southeastern services those are the
inpatient
services that we provide and they're at
different levels of care
and the outpatient treatment so that's
part of what's in this treatment
box and then impaired driving we always
forget that
um our actually our bureau
is in charge in overseeing the impaired
driving program
and again for your
purposes we talked about people paying
for services
when we were talking about new hampshire
hospital the
individuals who are court ordered into
this particular program
pay for the program it's a self-pay and
so therefore
it is um self-funded
so to speak do their payments exceed the
costs
are you making a profit in other words
i don't believe that we're making a
profit i
i believe that it is a break-even
situation
government is generally not permitted to
make a profit so
i think well we call it something
different
but that there's a surplus of funds that
are reallocated to other cost centers
right no we that isn't the case in this
and then the supports that are provided
as i said earlier as people go through
the continuum and go through recovery
and that includes the recovery community
organizations
which are overseen by a
facilitating organization that provides
all of the
administrative support for these
organizations
i believe we're up to 14 to 16
of these organizations across the state
and again
to orient you we have sos
on the seacoast and we have navigating
recovery in the lakes region
and a number of other organizations that
cover the entire state hope for new
hampshire recovery
in manchester and berlin those
programs are providing peer support
so rather than having a
medical model it is a model that's
nationally recognized
and supported
mostly by volunteers there are some paid
staff
but there are many many people in
recovery who want to give back
and they act as peer coaches with these
organizations
we have family support services these
are support groups
that are held throughout the state for
our families
and then recovery housing and so
we have been able to over the um
last couple of years put in some
standards
recovery housing and there is actually a
statute now that
only ones that have gone through
this certification process are able to
receive state funds
so we tighten the controls there are a
lot of concerns about
standards for this particular level of
housing
and those have been instilled and tied
so is there a supplementary slide
also in this deck that deals with all of
the
metrics of success how you how you're
determining
how successful you are or what kind of
workload you're dealing with
i would say there's just a sampling
there is not
a detailed um i can provide we can
provide additional information but it
was way too much
to include in a compressed time frame
okay if they don't already exist it just
may be a good
homework assignment over the next year
or two
sure and we've been working very closely
on that
in really focusing on outcomes and
evaluation
both of the state opioid response grant
dollars and grant funded programs as
well as our other programs so we have
a lot they're just not in a nice neat
package
but how about we share what we have
and then let you know what our plan is
so 125 contracts
anyone who has gone through a
contracting
process with us understands what that
takes
um and also what it takes to not only
contract and go and get the contract in
place but then to
oversee those contracts and so
statutorily required to carry out the
decisions
of the governor's commission on alcohol
and other drugs and
they alone i believe account for
maybe up to 50 of those contracts
and what we're able to do with the
governor's commission funding
is braid it with federal funds
and with state general funds to be able
to support all these services that you
see listed here
so to what extent are these actually
unique contracts versus model contracts
that have
minor changes between them so that's a
that's a really good point because it
makes it sound very daunting
so for example the treatment contracts
many of those
are the same contract that's only
the only difference may be
the amount of dollars that are awarded
in it
so that's a core contract and then
toggle to address population
and other needs in the community
but it's still 23 different
organizations that we're
interacting with and overseeing and
managing and auditing and
monitoring gets to be the bigger part
absolutely it's really important and i
know that you had
meredith telus here from quality and
performance and she talked a lot about
what is done in that arena
and we work side by side with her on
that
so again i said that there would be a
little bit of um
of data that we could provide so this is
individuals served and if
you want to dive deeper into how do we
get to that 80 000 number
i'd be happy to share that with you
prevention is an area where you see
where you make the investment that the
reward
is great a return and i know studies
have been done on that
and so the more people that we can reach
on the prevention and the less
number that we have to treat on the
acute
side
so again the doorways
this is interesting data because you see
some dips um and
as many of us have already been talking
about we've seen
changes and some anomalies that we
wouldn't have expected to see
due to the pandemic
so we're very pleased that the doorways
were able to maintain
contact with individuals that they were
already serving
and keep their doors open which may mean
keeping their
telephone lines open through telehealth
to be able to continue to serve
individuals and so we saw a big dip
and now it's it's starting to come back
up again
as as we all struggle through and learn
to live with
this is also very
much tied to the pandemic on the number
of people who
have been able to be in treatment
services
and again it either is because of
closures or not closures well closures
on a temporary basis where we had to
reduce
the census in the provider system
for social distancing as people were in
treatment
trying to maintain them in treatment
while dealing with all the
issues that they needed to deal with
through the pandemic so we saw those
admissions go
down as you'll hear i think from the
advocates
and for me right now we anticipate that
the demand is going to get
very very high in all of the services
that we provide through our division
and so we know about the
liquor sales and um the increase in that
we know that um there are many many
children who are
in uh crisis and um
from not being in school and having
their social supports
and we know that people have prolonged
their interaction with our services
um because of copen and so they come in
at a higher
in a more acute level so we're just
we're just getting started with our
and again this was a very successful um
endeavor through the pandemic where
we've seen
the increase in growth of peer recovery
support services
and we've been able to do that with
funds that have been afforded
through legislative action as well as
the state opioid response
and critical dollars from the governor's
commission that have supported
these organizations
how am i doing in time here
you tell me to get through this bureau
um i think you're on pace
good right so these are the positions
um one of the things that i'm sure
you've heard about is that we did have a
hiring freeze
as we were worried about state revenues
and what that was going to mean however
that has since been lifted and we're in
the process of filling these positions
so we were shorthanded and will continue
to be shorthanded until all those
and then these are just a couple of
benchmarks they're not the ones that
i think that you were speaking to mr
chair
but they are achievements that we've
been very pleased with but we have a lot
so the student assistance programs they
engage with you to provide prevention
and early intervention services
and typically right in the school
setting and
they were able to continue to have that
contact
with students in very creative ways
um as schools went remote
so this this is a this is a new slide
that i've requested so i just thought
i'd let you know what i
i was thinking when i asked for this
sort of thing
and and the way it's been presented in
in
other dhh slides is that on the left
there are the things that drive your
workflow
uh what metrics or
client load drive your workload and then
on the right
what quality measures you're using to
make sure that you're
you're doing a good job so the one on
the left is how much work the one on the
right is
you know how how well are you doing the
work
okay so that doesn't quite hit the mark
on this i'll go back and look at some of
those
no it's it's it's in the it's in the you
know
the horseshoe range okay
all right um
quality is always an area that we're
striving towards it's something that we
all expect
um and something that and we owe
to the people that we serve and it's
something that we continue to work on
um and then again the availability
engagement
in peer recovery support services so
um as you saw in the previous slide
we're growing
those services and want to continue to
so key accomplishments
um we have seen a decline in overdose
deaths
um at a time when other states have seen
increases so we feel that we're making
progress but
the death that is due to an overdose
is one too many and we're going to keep
going and going and going
on that and not take our foot off the
pedal
and we are able to very rapidly just as
the state employees were able to
quickly and i think dave readers
probably talked about this
go to remote work we've been able to
work with our providers who've been
amazing
and being able to make sure that they
could maintain
services and keep in touch with the
clients that they serve
um so there's more doorway information
they distribute naloxone that has been
critical
in addressing the overdose deaths that
that intervention
um has made a real difference um
you know let's see i'll just kind of go
through this quickly so that we
just about ten more minutes okay so for
prevention um
one of the things that the governor's
commission decided to do
when its funding was increased in the
last biennium
to 10 million dollars per year was to
invest in prevention because that's the
area that we all have to look to
when we're making really tough decisions
about budgets
and so they did a
investment that they referred to as
double down
on prevention and we're seeing
[Music]
so a sam so the american society of
addiction medicine
hat is a criteria that sets the level of
care
and that is a state requirement and how
we all work to determine
um if how long and
what type of treatment someone needs as
they
enter into the system so we used to call
them 28 day programs
and similar time stamped
programs now we look at these the acm
criteria and determine if someone can
move through it
more quickly or needs more time to get
through
on that stage in their recovery
and then um this is a
an e um an i.t area that we've looked at
challenges um as we all know that there
continues to be
the um lack of community acceptance in
some
areas um in substance misuse services
which then impacts our providers ability
to stand up services in particular
communities
there's workforce issues um not the
first time you've heard that not the
last time
you'll hear that and then the
um rapid growth
of the continuum of care so while we've
been
very grateful for the funding and the
support to grow
and transform this system it requires a
lot of work
and a lot of work from a lot of people
um
and so that's been a challenge um as
we've
budget so i'm going to linger on this
and ask if you have specific questions
so i would just mention here um the 20
20 20 21 in the middle there
uh you're seeing the general funds at 6
million and then go to 8.4 and 22.23
it's not um an increase in what has been
budgeted because 2020 is showing
actuals there and not budgeted if it
showed 2020 budget and 2021 budget
what you would see is that 6 million
number a lot closer to the 8.4
like many programs in in 2020 there has
been
federal funds which that's nice what's
that
so that um almost entirely is attributed
to the state opioid response funds
so um we received a significant
um so right now for example in this
federal fiscal year we got 28 million
dollars
and we also had carryover funds from
20. so that's where a lot of it comes
from we also
receive a um the the block grant
so samsa provides a block grant for
substance misuse
as well as for mental health and that is
7.2 million dollars
we have received word that we're going
to get
more funding but have yet to receive the
guidance or the notification
and we'll be needing to bring that forth
at some stage in the budget
um as we go forward um
the other thing i wanted to point out is
other funds
um so that's a huge number it's
obviously much bigger than
general funds and that is primarily the
the alcohol and drug commission the five
percent from the alcohol revenues is
that our
profits so what you're saying
so karen you want to handle that or you
want me to sure i can
touch on that yes it but the funding is
actually
um donations from the hospitals oh
that's a different thing okay so uh
representative waller did you give up on
me or you still have a question
no i'm i'm set thank you she answered it
my question is these inc this rather
significant increase in federal funds in
the next biennium
do we have reason to think that they'll
continue into the biennium beyond this
do we know don't we don't know
we don't know you know new hampshire has
done so well
in the state opioid response
um that we
need that funding to continue that
momentum
however the fundamental formula under
state opioid response
has been based on our numbers and how
we're how many
overdose deaths we've had um so
hopefully that formula doesn't change
and that will continue
to be able to receive these funds but
that
is really a subject for congress to
tackle
any other questions on this slide want
okay the good and the bad so
um if we were to get a five percent
increase
um the um
i would emphasize the bottom one on that
uh
top of the top three so rather than
focusing on beta staff which is
really really important as you can see
from
what we're required to carry out but i
think it also looks at
sustaining the new initiative so your
point is
you know is that federal funding going
to continue so that we can sustain
um the current structure in the current
system
um the five percent would help us in
that arena
um and then the um workforce development
again you've already heard about that
quite a bit and we'd be able to continue
to
invest in workforce so
the um the bed would be
that we would reduce staff and we would
need to
look at cutting existing programs
for example um some of those contracts
that we've talked about
that are funded through all those
graded sources we would have to look at
those in the general funds that are
committed to those
and i'm not sure if those would able to
be able to be sustained
through federal funding and through the
governor's commission
which are very hesitant the governor's
commission to invest in anything
that the state is not supporting on its
own
sure and also i'm sorry
don't finish your thought go forward um
i just wanted to say we do have a
maintenance of effort requirement for
our federal
uh block grant the 7.2 that i mentioned
so we have always have to look to make
sure that we're meeting that
so my general observation on this slide
is
these are nice concepts but i don't see
anything measurable here
so i don't i don't know how to evaluate
what these words mean in terms of
be happy to come back with something
more definitive if
that is your pleasure i think
i think we'll need it because every
program is going to have to
really be looked at from this
perspective and the
better each program is able to
articulate
something that can be measured uh i
think it just makes their argument
stronger
that's my thought but every committee
member has her own
so all right
what else um we could take the actual
dollar
amount and then really um drill down on
that of what that five percent
so here are the accounting units and
to look at an accounting sheet does
somebody have an accounting sheet
for us to look at why not so katya if
you want to stop sharing i'll go ahead
and share
the accounting units if i could just
break in for a second here i'm not sure
if you saw the
email representative edwards but the
gopher meeting has been postponed until
friday so i'm not sure if that changes
your plans or not
it could it depends on if representative
walner and wyler were looking for an
excuse to leave well
thanks mr ripple thanks we've got to get
through this one time or another if that
gopher meetings on friday fine
we'll keep going all right let's go
ahead let's let's go ahead and look at
great okay so we're going to start on
page 1108
which is accounting unit 2070
and i would just mention that jane
jackson is also on the line she is the
finance director uh for the division of
behavioral health and you will also see
her with the division of long-term
supports and services
so the first say hello to jane jackson
because i haven't seen her in about
25 years when she worked at rockingham
county
we did steal here from rockingham county
and are very grateful
for that knows the numbers very well yes
she has been a great addition to our
team we're very thankful
so accounting unit 2070 is program
operations for
uh bureau of drug and alcohol services
so this is where the bureau chief it's
the administrative
can we on this one go down to the the
personnel
leveling from uh budget to budget right
yeah right in there
so we've got a plus up of just one
yes and i i believe that i provided all
the detail to kevin
of all of the position moves throughout
so is this a position move or is this a
new
creation was this a conversion
gene or was this a move um this would
have been
a ps4 that's new for um
help with recovery initiatives
so was it moved from somewhere else
though or was it a temporary position
that we converted to permanent
um i believe it was moved from um
78.77 we had a few positions that were
budgeted
in the main um 9200 which we kind of
briefly went over and skipped the
accounting information on
and one of them ended up in this
division
questions from the committee on on this
area
this this looks pretty straightforward
it's
being driven by the ftes for the most
part right
yes
okay let's we can continue okay that
accounting
unit's not being used uh 3380 is the
next one which is prevention services
so the total almost doubles right
am i reading that right
yes and that looks like it's because of
agency income uh
gene where is the agency income coming
from in
in this accounting unit um the agency
income in this accounting unit
is from the settlement funds not sure if
if you are you want to talk a little bit
more about those but that is where we
budgeted for
the settlement funds and you'll note
that
um in an upcoming accounting unit um
3395 which is
our um pfs2
grant it's coming to an end and so some
of the contract
initiatives that were taken care of with
that grant funding
have been moved to prevention services
so you'll see
um a jump in the
contract line actually now it's up in
line 074 which is
where we moved some of our contracts to
a grants line if they were considered a
sub-recipient so you'll see a shift from
contracts in 102 from the prior year
shifting up to 0.74
grants for public assistance that you'll
see an increase there and that's what
that
is accounted by so the settlement money
is that opioid settlement it's not
tobacco settlement right
no not tobacco sediment opioid sediment
which are
uh go ahead so that's that's
that's uh that's a new source of money
relative to the
past budgets it's a new anticipated
source of revenue
there are several um i believe lawsuits
contain might be able to speak to it
better
related to to opioids and
anticipated funds that will flow through
to the state
there is a a opioid abatement advisory
commission for which i am the uh
designee of the commissioner to sit upon
actually our first meeting is friday
morning which is why we're starting a
little bit late on friday morning
and that committee advises the
department on how to spend the funds
so this is an area that we we sort of
are
hoping to be able to do that uh
ultimately the commissioner makes the
final decision on how those funds are
spent but that commission advises on it
so
this will be something that we'll be
discussing with that commission as time
goes on
for that settlement money do we have a
state matching requirement for any of it
that we know of
not to my knowledge now it's not a grant
i'll just point out um that this
has already received one um
or at least it's going to be receiving
some funding from
mckinsey settlement um and so you'll
hear
names of the different manufacturers
and different players that have been
sued over the opioid
epidemic and so there already is a chunk
of
funding and we anticipate receiving
additional funds
hopefully this spring as we're
developing the
any other questions on 33.80
no just make sure
right here at 33.82
are these the the alcohol
revenues uh they are not the alcohol
revenues they
are donations from the hospitals
okay so all right so you already said
that once i thought that was in a
different section
nope so i think that the uh alcohol
revenues that you are thinking of
karen they i should point out probably
they do pass through us
they do pass through and then they get
transferred over to
the medicaid division that's a good
okay the next accounting unit here
starts at the bottom of this page
3384. i need reading glasses i have not
been to the eye doctor since covid
uh um
and continues on to the next stage i'm
having to lean in so much to see the
numbers that people can do an
ophthalmology exam
[Music]
okay
so this is relatively level funded yes
the major change here is the one that
we've talked about in a couple other
presentations where we're moving it from
to 74. for better tracking purposes for
all right are there any questions here
the next one is 33.85 the drug
forfeiture fund
[Music]
just a two what is a drug forfeiture
fund
[Music]
i'm waiting to see if jane responds so
that
is um transferred from i believe it
is the um department of
safety i think it's
um department of justice i believe
i'll have to check back but i do that's
right and this tied to the civil asset
forfeiture so if we bust a drug dealer
and
take their property that that's what
this money is
exactly it's a percentage of that that's
um to come to us
yes thank you
okay and then starting at the bottom of
the page is 3393 which is
uh the treatment drug court grant
which i believe ended so it's no longer
budgeted
so then coming down to uh 3395 which is
the pfs
2 grant which katie was speaking about
earlier
that ends in during fiscal year 22 so
we've moved that budgeting in 23 up to
that previous accounting unit where you
all right moving down to 6935 which is
the match grant that also ended in
fiscal year 21 so that is no longer
budgeted
what does matt stand for medically
i believe we now use some of the state
opioid response funds for
some medically assisted treatment
contracts which is
also the accounting unit on this page
here which is 70 40.
so that might have been how we paid for
narcan
and stuff it's all right
i'm just talking let's let's keep going
70 40.
yes this is the large grant that um that
you
we were mentioning is what increased the
federal funds
across this bureau we have gone to
fiscal
committee for fiscal year 21 already to
accept those funds and then we are
so
it seems to me like the the fiscal the
finance
committee division three that we
probably need
a decent understanding of
of what is driving that dollar amount
and how predictable we see that amount
in the out years
and whether or not we need a state match
at all for any of that
is is this subject to that level of
effort of 7.2 million or was that
so uh mr chair that was something else
that's our
core funding that we've received for
years and years and years that currently
is about 7.2 million dollars and that's
our block grant
slr funding does not have any
maintenance of effort or match it only
cannot be used to match medicaid
so we can't take the funds and then
you know a medicaid expense for opioid
treatment
and then use these particular funds for
that it has to be something that could
not be funded otherwise
okay and so the plan for this is
primarily
there on grants
for public assistance and relief
so again that class line 74 is the one
that we're using
to represent sub-recipient monitoring
you remember we talked about that last
week that um
the department of administrative
services was unable to uh
create a class line for us that said
sub-recipient
so that was the class line we used that
we've not used previously that made the
most sense
so just remind me in a sentence or two
what
what are we paying for with that uh 25
so be happy to so um you mentioned
naloxone so we're buying naloxone
and spending a considerable amount on
that
we also stood up the doorway programs
so and any non-medicaid billable
services
that may involve what staff are doing
the rent the all of the
services to have those doorways open and
ready to go
and as part of the doorway system
they enter the system through two one
one
and so we have these nine doorways
across the state
um that are open typical business hours
we have a couple that are open on
weekends
and then we also have after hours
coverage
um so that there is 24 7
access and that includes clinicians who
are available
after hours we also
provide as i said
the funding for the recovery community
organizations they're funded out of that
um to a quite a considerable amount
we have medication assisted treatment um
there
that is a medicaid billable service
however there are individuals who
are still remain uninsured or
underinsured
and there are many services that are
supporting
medication assisted treatment that are
not medicaid
reimbursed i'd be happy to share with
you our grant application which was
awarded
that has all of the um individual
components that make up that 28 million
do it in a half a page or are you going
to send me a 400 page document
i will send you at whatever you would
like
i could run the half page category okay
okay
25 million is a decent chunk of money
i'm just
curious you know if i i imagine you're
using it well
we are stretching it to the extent that
we can
and one thing i should note is that the
previous
opioid response grants were only to
assist individuals who were addicted to
opioids
and now they've loosened that up to
stimulants
as well and you may have seen a recent
news article and a lot of talk
around different uh tables about
the concerns that we have about the
rising use of stimulants
in the state i did actually
thank you we've had a few pages here
excuse me we had a few pages that didn't
have any class
10 but they put the class 60
for the benefits is it all temp
full-time people in these
yes it would be their temporary
full-time or temporary part-time in this
on this accounting unit it's temporary
full-time
why do they get is that because it's
fairly new program and you
haven't settled things out yet or what's
the reason to have it full time
yes we we try not to create permanent
positions unless we know that it's
permanent funding
so we leave it as a temporary position
if if it's tempora what we
think could be temporary funding so in
this case we would not make them
permanent positions because we don't
know if it's permanent funding
i can remember in conversations in the
past somebody said well we've got
somebody
in our office with 20 years and he's
i understand and sometimes it's because
that
you know every congress does end up
renewing the grant but it
it's it isn't for sure
thank you you're welcome are there any
okay we can go on so that's actually the
last accounting unit in bdas so i'm not
sure if you want to
um switch over to uh
to katya and do the next um bureau
but yeah we still have two more bureaus
right
yes and and what does it make more sense
to you to do both bureaus and then the
accounting or just
like we did before do the bureau and
then the accounting
i'm sorry i was trying to find my unmute
uh
button so typically i feel dead air so
if you hear dead air like that you know
i'm having some technical difficulty
all right bureau for children's
behavioral health i think this
is going to take us a considerable
amount of time because i want to address
all the questions that you have and so
um kevin i think that we're going to
need to bring up
erica ungarelli we don't need to
initially
but i think the level of conversation
that was
to be had this morning will necessitate
her participation
um because she really has the subject
matter
expertise and the knowledge about this
system and what we're trying to achieve
so so while all that's happening and if
it's going to take a lot let's go ahead
and take a five
and you guys can you can get everything
um
okay um i think we have a quorum
uh representative weiler's not back yet
katya something strange happened with
your screen sharing i know
maybe if you stop share and try again
okay
you know chris santaniello had dave
weeders walk by
so i don't have the luxury of him being
right across
from me ah there we go
is that better yes okay
i can't see any of you but i'm sure
you'll stop me when you need
to um
there we go okay so the bureau
for children's behavioral health um
so we talked a lot about
i should say that the bureau of drug and
alcohol services
serves all populations the bureau for
children's behavioral health was created
right after the division
was formed so it was established in may
of 2016 so not quite five years ago
and the idea was to really elevate
the children's issues by having a
very intense focus on children's
behavioral health needs
and so the bureau looks at
children youth and young adults up to 21
that's a key piece and
they have been identified as having a
behavioral health concern
and requiring services
so they bureau
overseas the publicly funded programs
to treat children and identify them
as well as to provide those services
and support the families again as we
talk about this
those family supports are really
important
and then the bureau also as all of us do
oversees the contracts and service
providers in the system
to ensure that they are being responsive
and we are being responsive to the
population needs
and so as i mentioned on the outset that
this is really governed by the system of
care values
which were established through a very
very robust stakeholder process
so erica created these slides and i
think it
really really talks about over the last
five years the type of growth that we've
seen in this area
and it's been exciting and daunting at
the same time
so we started off with two staff members
and then they had their particular
programs that they
worked with um for the funding that was
allocated
and then the initiatives that were going
on
two years ago we doubled the staff size
that's a big number
except it's small um and we started
adding some
additional initiatives and some
different um accountabilities for this
particular bureau
and its uh expanse
here we are today so we've essentially
doubled the staff again
um in recognition of all of the work
that was
going on and the opportunities that we
had
to really full fully build out that
system of care
and so we have as you've seen through
all the slides the time community mental
health centers
and i apologize for any acronym um
i had communication with erica earlier
i'm like remind me what's this what's
this so
if you have any questions about any of
them please let me know
and so then we have care
management entities um and they provide
intensive in-home supports as well as
peer support we have
grants treatment providers
peer providers we have an assessment
tool that's used to look at the
strengths and needs
of a particular child in their family
we are in the process of the mobile
crisis
implementation that was mentioned
earlier today
we have in-state residential
treatment providers and we've developed
an
infant mental health plan knowing that
the earlier that we can start addressing
needs
the better there are major initiatives
that are going on and they may look like
they're separate and distinct but they
really
are part of that system of care and so
i'm going to
actually skip right so cancer cancer's
an i.t system that's the clinical
assessment system
it is it's a it's web-based i believe
is that correct erica is erica on
that is correct hey aaron nice to see
you erica
again the director of the bureau for
children's behavioral health
representative wallner has a question
while we're here and i see mobile crisis
units there
um what has been the delay
in getting these um how and we gave you
in the last budget do we give you
funding for two
i can't remember him let me yeah i'll
explain and then eric
can talk a little bit about that so
we've had three mobile crisis
units in the state and i'm going to go
right to this one because you'll see
statewide mobile crisis right here down
at the bottom
so we've had those they were established
as part of the community mental health
agreement which was a court settlement
known as amanda d
and we're required to set up those three
teams
in concord manchester and nashua
and we've done that it has been
abundantly
apparent that to address
children's needs and to address adults
needs families needs
all population needs that mobile crisis
most effective way to
intervene when someone is experiencing a
behavioral health
crisis so that they don't end up in the
institutions that we've talked about so
they don't end up in the emergency
departments
they don't end up in um need
of the hampstead hospital for example
level of care that we have that
intervention
in the community so everything that we
do if we
um in most circumstances want to do
in the community there are some
circumstances where it can't happen
um so that is the model so as part of
sb14 the idea was a statewide children's
mobile crisis response we looked at the
funding
we looked at the workforce we looked at
the provider capacity
and we determined that we could not just
stand up a children's mobile crisis
and um ignore the rest of the family
ignore
the fact that there really should be
access for all populations to mobile
crisis
statewide and i know that our friend ken
norton would be happy to talk about this
because he's been
um someone who supported this from day
one
so what we did was we developed the
model
of what that would look like and that
doesn't include just okay stand up a
team
and they go and do this work that is
part of the transformation that we
want to achieve which is to have
emergency response and so typically
emergency services
happen in the emergency department and
so that's typically where people are
getting that intervention
the idea is to transform that and
have all those interventions
with the exception of the few that are
needed happen
in the community happen in people's
homes happen
in different community settings
happen in schools happen at
perhaps a police department's involved
but to have those happen there
and not in that
emergency department where treatments
delayed
and a whole bunch of things cascade
and do a trajectory that is not
necessarily the outcome that we want to
see for these children
and for the for adults as well
so the delay so we were again
um affording money
and having a system be able to respond
to what we
are looking at is a recall of
our emergency response it's just not a
matter again
of setting up a team you hire a couple
of people and they go around with a
um with a van and say we're mobile
response
we have an rfp that was issued we're in
the process
of getting that finalized
for a centralized dispatch center so to
speak
that can provide statewide
coverage with one phone number instead
of the hundreds of phone numbers that we
have out there when someone wants to
call their
community mental health center or call
some some provider and find help
they'll be one phone number for them to
access
and determine on the this
particular entity will be a hub so to
speak
and be able to dispatch
in the community and do that screening
and assessment
initially so that we don't bring out the
police if the police don't need to
intervene
we don't um you know over burden a
system
we really determine um what that level
of need is
in that initial screening and then we
have the regional teams
that are able to respond based on what
the need is so there may be
resolution um through telephone and
there may be resolution through that
in person face to face so that
has um been our vision
and that's what we want to see however
we had a pandemic
and throughout that pandemic we did
everything we could to
really hold together a system that was
fragile
so we had workforce issues prior to the
pandemic we have
workforce issues today we have
readiness for our providers to be able
to stand up these services
and we also had the
procurement process which was also
delayed because our contracts unit
which i can't remember if you've had
that presentation yet
they were down staff they had a huge
vacancy
level and um they had hundreds and
hundreds of contracts to
execute for pandemic response
so all of those informational items that
you see on the governor on council
agenda they were behind those in
for the department in getting those
contracts in place so that we could get
all of the emergency services we needed
to respond to the pandemic
so it is not for a lack of
money and it's not for lack of
hard work by erica and her team
and all of the people that we work with
it's just
was a matter of trying to transform a
system when we had an earthquake
and we're just trying to fill in those
fissures
instead of um and really stabilize it
and we're still trying to stabilize it
we still have residential providers
who have um you know quarantine issues
they have bed space
capacity issues they have staff that are
out
um so i get pretty passionate about
the fact that we're getting criticized
um in many many fronts for not having
this stood up yet but there are so many
factors
that go into that um and
we are doing everything we can and we're
still
on track to be able to go into contract
and have this ready to go um in the next
several months
could i ask one further question yes
so could you so right now
did i understand you said we have three
that are operating and they've been
operating for a while
i don't know how many years but quite a
while right
yes and you're and you're authorized to
contract for two more
that right no no we're just to have
statewide mobile crisis
there's no number on that we just have
to care
have statewide coverage okay okay so
we're looking at transforming the system
so when we think about it it's not
exactly the same model that we saw in
manchester nashua and concord
a different approach to responding to
mr chair any additional questions um
that's i'm not seeing any and i have
trivia questions to ask you but i'll let
you continue
okay i'll let that pass and keep moving
forward
so um this is really a slide about the
system of care
it talks about the different levels of
care which
is something that we're in the process
of implementing through
our procurements we've had many
procurements um
the result of taking this slide
and operationalizing it and so
when you look at um
kind of just pick one out in particular
um so we've had a series of the
initiatives that have been put in place
this is some transformation that
requires
um building blocks you can't just start
anywhere and just start throwing it out
there and say oh this is the easiest
thing to do so let's go procure for that
this really had building blocks so
hiring
erica's staff was a building block
because we needed to have the
wherewithal and the ability within the
department
to move these initiatives forward and so
then we had
um we had coped and we
needed to stand some things up pretty
quickly one was
on the care management entity for the
fast forward program
and fast forward fast is
families and systems together and it's a
high
fidelity wrap around model that's used
to address children's and families needs
and one of the major
levels of effort is the levels of care
so
there was the establishment and this was
done with hundreds of stakeholders who
participated in this process
and helped informed the levels of care
for residential treatment we often
find ourselves not having the level of
care that we need
in our state and so um individuals
have had to we've had to work with um
other states to find placements to get
the right level of care
this um is a procurement that is
currently out i believe it closes within
the next couple of weeks
um and so we have um these
levels that will then be able to provide
the right level of care at the right
time
and you had mentioned earlier i believe
we talked about
the children's level
and what is needed this psychiatric
and hospitalization piece
is the step down or step up
um it's just below the level of care
that we've been talking about with
inpatient acute stays at
hempstead and now at new hampshire
hospital on a temporary basis
and so that's that's a program that
we've wanted to support for a number of
years
and that also is subject to a
i think i'll pause here and let you read
through and see if you have any specific
questions because i think
a lot of it has been addressed and this
like the workload measurements thank you
it's nice to know how much work is
so go ahead
representative wallner had a question i
think on that slide right there
so well i don't know that it's i don't
know that it's on this slide but this
seems like a place where i might be able
to
to ask this um
there was the suit that was brought
against
the the department a few years ago the
community mental health and then we had
the community mental health agreement
and on a fairly regular basis i don't
know what it is
a couple of times a year maybe a
quarterly it gets reviewed by the
by an expert yes how are we how
are we doing on it i mean i kind of
kind of glimpsed at the most recent
report
and it seemed like um we're still out of
compliance in certain areas
but i wondered if you could talk for a
minute about those areas and this might
not be the right slide i didn't know
where to put this in
so so um mr chair
i would request that we hold that
until we get to the bureau of mental
health services
the bureau for mental health services
addresses the adult population
which is the subject of the community
mental health agreement
the committee mental health agreement
does not address children's services
great thank you thank you yeah let's do
that
representative walter is fine with that
yeah let's put that in the parking lot
great
data to provide to you and so this
really shows um the number of children
that are being served by the committee
of the health centers um that just say
centers instead of services
um i believe but we've seen that growth
and
i think that we have heard um from
others
previously about why we're seeing these
increases
so i'm curious about this data within a
different
uh assessment you know
how many of these clients
i'm just sort of curious about the
demographics here
so i think that's something i just saw
erica shake her head so i think that's
something we'll have to take back and
see if we can
um bring back to you and do it
by age cohorts actually i can answer
that if you would like
and then and then i'd be curious about
the complimentary slide that could go
with it which would be
who are we not servicing are there
communities
that we should be uh addressing where
we're just not doing a great job of
getting um
so again um erica did she could address
the 18 plus
and i think she'd be happy to entertain
me second question as well
absolutely so this uh client count
actually
does not include 18 to 21 year olds
those will be represented in julian
carbon's
uh graphs for the adopt mental health
side we are in the process of adjusting
our rules
for the child eligibility to go
up to 21 but this is not represented
here yet
i would say in that pain that is one
area where we need to have some focused
attention
is engaging and that
young adult transitional aged adult age
group
in uh more targeted engagement
and more targeted services for that age
group
okay so earlier one of the departments
said they considered
essentially said not literally but
essentially said that they considered
adulthood to begin at 18.
so it's it's sounding a little bit like
we have
multiple divisions aiming at servicing
that 18 to 21 year
age group and i just wonder if
if that's by design and if it's a smart
design
or if we are maybe making a mistake
having two different
divisions trying to take care of the
mental health of that
age group so go ahead erica
your thoughts on that certainly when our
bureau is
uh established we really wanted to align
who we care for with
other entities such as schools who take
care of
and educate kids up to 21 if they have a
severe emotional disturbance and have
an iep that requires them to be in
school
till 21 so that we don't cause any sort
of cliff effect
experience
okay so the the other part of that
question and
maybe it's just something for the
department to talk about
is just making sure that they uh
there's clarity around who owns what
part of a mission for the 18 to 20 year
olds
because it sounds like there's more than
one bureau or more than one division
that does
so it just in my past it just seems like
when
more than one group is responsible for
something it causes problems
um so i would just say that yes there
are multiple divisions that serve
people who are 18 to 21 depending on
their needs and what services they
qualify for i think the
the last presentation you heard about
was chris from chris santaniello
um and i think that there were different
eligibilities
for programs that provide
the provide payments potentially to
people in that age group
i think that behavioral health-wise
erica has explained what's covered here
the other area that you will hear about
18 to 21 year olds
would be over in developmental
disabilities um
which i believe that presentation is
next week but i would say that as far as
coordination
that i i from what i've seen coming from
a different department the directors
here
coordinate very very well um between
programs there's always more work to be
done
but it certainly isn't siloed to the
point that they don't know what the
others are doing
i think i think we heard that the path
center
the youngest person could be was 18 to
be over
in that building for example so
okay so this um slide talks about um the
eligibility category
and um so there are different
eligibility
categories that we have um and this is
um it shows all the trending is up
um and if there are specific questions
about eligibility
um now would be the time to ask them and
i think
erica would be prepared to answer those
questions
so cmhc that's community mental health
that's correct that's a community mental
health centers
and so the 10 centers that are
designated
across the state example on concord you
have river bend in manchester you have
manchester mental health
you have sea coast mental health you
have northern human services in the
north country etc
okay
are there any questions here from any
anyone
so i think i mentioned before cme is
care
management entity um that oversees the
um fast forward program and the
wraparound services
and you'll see the number of enrolled
has continued to increase and so this is
an
area of growth that we
have moved to having to two
so you'll see this one and by the way
i'm so proud of myself
nfi which you see here which is a
provider
of housing services on campus as we
talked about earlier
um is north eastern family institute
and so they are very similar to kfc
they're never known as kentucky fried
chicken they're always known
by their acronym which is in this case
nfi
very good so that new hampshire hospital
can cross that off their list of things
to get back to you
so we have to get back to them and tell
them to put the e in there if they're
northeast
that's right all right
um and so we um just got this
in place in october which seems like
yesterday
um which is the second um care
management entity
because of the anticipated growth and
you can see
that they're ramping up their services
to provide
the services they cover mostly the
monadnock region in the western part of
the state
while nfi covers statewide
um i do want to mention because this
impacts when you look at the staffing
for the bureau is that we determine
so the key accomplishments
erica did an amazing job of hiring in
staff and onboarding them during the
pandemic
so um as you can imagine that was
difficult
um but has been very successful it did
help that we were able to hire some
individuals who already were working
within the department and wanted to take
on
the new initiatives and the excitement
so the 10-year mental health plan um
when we talk about that i think people
default to
thinking that it addresses adults
because our previous plan
that was established in 2008
only addressed adults and we were about
and determined
that in this current mental health plan
that it would cover all populations
and put an emphasis on children
okay so i have to ask how would one
assess an infant to determine if they
have mental health
issues that's a very good question erica
would you
um erica was very involved in the
development of this mental health plan
and i will say that we partnered with
other parts of the department
and so henry littman our medicaid
director was also involved in the
development of this plan
through a initiative that was funded by
i believe the national governors
association that recognized this was an
area that needed attention go ahead
erica
certainly that's a question that we get
asked a lot and it's a question i had
a few years ago before i went to that
training in minnesota
so there is a diagnostic manual
for infants and very young children
that is a companion to the diagnostic
manual
clinicians use for diagnosing
uh older children and adults so there is
a companion
piece there um and so most of it
centers around the infant and
any sort of growth development or
milestone
not being achieved and
there's a focus on sort of
sleep feeding and crying
issues um that may uh an
infant a parent of an infant may
experience
and then there's also an emphasis on the
parent child
bond so there are things when you're
assessing
um i think everybody's fairly familiar
with
a developmental assessment of an infant
if milestones aren't being reached
that's definitely
an area of concern and would need uh
some medical rule out but also could be
attributed to some behavioral health
issues that can be addressed
um let's go to the next step
let's let's let's say that that in fact
you can't assess the mental health of an
infant
since most of our mental health
treatment these days seems to be with
psychotropic
interventions are we is
what are we doing if we assess infant
with mental health issues are we
drugging them we're certainly not
counseling them we are not we're
educating the parents
and we are treating the parent-child
bond most of our infant work
is about uh the return and response with
between a caregiver and an infant so
that is what is emphasized in treatment
so a lot of focus on the parent and the
parent education as well
so doesn't that get um filtered through
a bunch of different cultural lenses of
what a parent-child relationship ought
to be
i mean there's not just one way to
parent child
there are multiple cultures so
absolutely
i'm still having problems figuring out
what
what we could do effectively in this
area
correct so all of our services need to
be
uh looking through the lens of cultural
competence
um so if you are serving a family and a
child
that is experiencing issues that is from
a different culture of yours you
need really need to be you know
educating yourself
on what those cultural standards are
during that but it's really all about
focusing
on the issues that may bring a child
to a uh assessment of this
nature um you know or what is found
through a primary care will child check
and those developmental
milestones not being achieved so if
everything else can be ruled out then we
need to look
more closely on at the behavioral health
the home environment and the parent
okay um so someday not in this budget
cycle i'd like to
talk about how you measure effectiveness
of a program like that i don't
i don't know how you get your arm around
success metrics
but anyways that's too much to be
determined actually
that's part of our development that we
have to determine what those
metrics will look like okay great thank
you
so getting on to key challenges i think
um
you're gonna start see seeing some
repeats here
um so workforce again
um the
system expansion is really hard to do
when you're just holding on
the medicaid primary funder for the
services
developed by children's behavioral
health and
so we use state general funds to fill in
the gaps
when we cannot bill medicaid
um and so we've seen children enter the
system
through the pandemic that have never
ever entered the system before
so some of those children are
commercially insured
and some of them are um have are in
families that aren't too short
insured and but really working we've
been working with the legislature
actually on this commercial insurance
side
because medicaid will pay for services
um that we've built up over time
that commercial insurance has yet to
catch up to
so we need to make sure that we're
addressing all children's needs
rather than just those who are on
medicaid
and then again looking at the staffing
um
in transformation of the system and
overseeing the network throughout the
pandemic
we work very closely with the department
of education
in overseeing the system of care because
that is a
statute that addresses both departments
working together
knowing how critical it is with
and i think i hope karen is here
um but she may or may not be but jane
should be there's karen oh i'm here i'm
here i'm multitasking sorry
yeah um so the charts here
this is similar to the other part chart
with 20
20 and 2021 and representative walner
was
referencing this earlier that if the
funds
had been contracted um in a
more timely way in 2020 the general
funds would look very similar
in that middle pie chart compared to the
pie chart on the right
the new other funds coming in there
are a grant that doe has received
that they are working with us on
so that's what those funds coming up uh
in
i i was just going to say the the large
increase in general funds which i know
katya has spoken about
is really bringing that children's
system of care together and
bringing those contracts in place
all which will help
dcyf quite a bit in the future
to reduce the number of children um
i don't want to i don't want to sound
mean but
i i probably can't help it here
how do we know i mean it's we have a
theory that
early intervention even at the infant
level is going to
result in some some successes
but we don't have any way to measure it
so we don't actually
know whether or not this is a valid
theory at this point
so how do we how do we say money
invested now
is is we're sure is going to positively
influence the dcyf community in the
future
i'm i'm missing something there
so i'm sure katya will jump in there but
i would also just suggest that you also
ask that question of joe ripsom because
this is a system that they stood up in
new jersey where he worked previously
um so he has some lived experience with
it as well
okay all right go ahead katya yeah and
i'll just quickly mention that
evidence-based practices that have been
proven to be effective
are um what we're employing so
when we implement something we look at
first to see if it's an
evidence-based practice or a promising
practice
that has been tested and studied and
researched
in implementing that to really get at
those
outcomes that you're talking about and
we're going to be measuring this it's
not like we're just going to
spend money and have no accountability
with that
so we're going to be measuring it as we
go along i did want to point out
something that you'll see i believe it's
a class note
um in hb1 this
children's behavioral health has been
one area in this division
which has not had non-lapsing language
between
the two years that make up the biennium
so we did have
funds i know there's been concerns that
have been raised about lapse funds for
children's behavioral health
those funds would not have labs if we
had had that language that allowed us to
carry the
funding um from 20 to 21.
and so um again that was
something that we needed to put in and
it's in there and
we're also working with a legislature
on some on a bill that
would not allow the funds to lapse at
the end of the biennium but to carry
forward the funds
so that they remain committed to this
effort
lots of questions here representative
wallner
i just wanted to know whether or not
they depart whether or not the
children's behavioral health area
received
all the funding that they requested
and what what were the pre did you have
anything on your priority list that you
so and unless somebody jumped up and
down we did receive all the funding that
was requested to stand to continue these
services
and um there were no prioritized needs
um because they were everything was um
already
no that's what i wanted to know thank
thank you mr chair the way i see this
going is we won't rest until we have 100
percent of the children
having an annual psychiatric exam as
well as an annual
physical i mean it's it's just there's
lots of things that i've
witnessed in myself and my children
growing up and my grandchildren they
have
you know dream worlds they live in for a
while and they grow up and you know
some of these things were so deep that
uh
one grandson could only be referred to
as batman he wouldn't answer to his own
name
for a matter of months but i mean
this kind of thing we we suddenly called
in mental health people and i don't you
know
he outgrew it in six or eight months so
some of these things i think are
overreacting
and this growing a bigger and bigger
percentage of the children
who are likely just going through normal
phases of growth
it just doesn't make sense that this is
growing this much
i don't think we have this bigger
problem in our society
so could i suggest a possible way to
address
representative weiler's comment and and
it sort of uh would feed my issue too
and that is you say we're using
evidence-based
models it would be nice to get kind of a
summary
of what we're doing you know what what
what evidence are we looking at
what is is that within this budget cycle
i i don't know maybe it has to be um
but but at this point we have a lot of
programs that we know
are addressing real
medical needs that need to be funded
so this gets to the five percent um
up and down um and so you can see where
we would expand
um we talked about the infant mental
health we've talked about the care
management entity and their capacity
you saw the growth in that um and the
increased demand for those services
erica told us i forget how many
applications they're getting a day for
individuals seeking those particular
services
and then we would look at enhancing
communities treatment options
to therapeutic day treatment and
intensive outpatient treatment
i will say just um to go back to the
previous slide where we see the huge
jump in general funds
we are working on a couple of
initiatives that would allow us to
match those funds with medicaid and so
while some services
aren't currently covered by medicaid
we're hoping that
we can use that as a tool and a resource
to be able to garner that 50 percent
on some of those funds so the
decrease we would have wait lists for
those
high fidelity wrap around services
we would not be able to move forward
with the mental health
plan for infants and would only be able
to
do it on a pilot basis or a very
targeted basis
and we would not be able to support
those children who aren't currently
covered
there's the nine step that we've talked
about
and benchmarks
um so again fast forward program we have
been able to
keep up we're worried about keeping up
but we have been able to do that with
additional staffing resources that were
provided
the quality assurance reviews
are really important
and then the assistance and con
consultation for the children's
behavioral health programming
i don't i can't tell you um the demand
on erica's time and
for her staff they are constantly
bombarded
um with requests to provide that
technical assistance
and to present um information about
children's behavioral health
um and so that's across the board within
internal
all right and then i'm going to turn it
over to karen
if you want to stop screen sharing i'll
go ahead sorry
i'll try not to do a bunch of other
things at the same time
okay so we're gonna start on page one
one one
eight which um
has only the title of this accounting
unit so i'm gonna go ahead and go to
page one one one nine
which is accounting unit 2052 children's
behavioral health
and this has further accounts associated
with it right
yes this is uh really like the other
area is the administrative part of the
bureau
so i can go ahead and go down to the
next one which is
2053 which is the system of care the
so in 20 we were spending
about 1.8 million and we're proposing in
are those are those all general funds
for the most part there
is about 750 000 of federal funds
um and a little bit of other funds which
is that grant
from the department of education yeah
and i will tell you based on what i know
of and have seen for contracting
activity in this area
um this year i i do believe that we will
spend most of those funds in 22 and 23.
very good any questions here
you need another moment to look at it
represent walnut
weiler bean i just think it's
unsustainable growth we don't have the
revenue coming in to support this kind
of growth
where does this department think the
45 in general funds and so many of these
things
we don't have that kind of revenue we
don't have the kind of revenue sources
these are just not going to work so
so what what if you were to um
look out to the next biennium is this
or is this uh kind of this uh
geometric progression going to continue
next
katya do you have any insight or erica i
i would not anticipate that it would
grow
at this um we had a system that wasn't a
system
we're building a system to address the
needs of children
and to get to the point of how do we
talk about
cost avoidance i think we look at
division two
and our division three one whichever one
and look at the cost in safety and look
at the costs in our criminal justice
system
and so um if we get this system
in place we're going to have the
services
and the supports that are needed for
families
and children that will really have a
significant
impact on families in the future and
where they end up in the trajectory
of children we always think in two-year
terms
but we really when we're building a
system like this we're looking
representative yes um
erica and katja i i'm wondering um
what's what do what do people talk about
at the federal level about um
a children's system of care and um
do you see a future there that the
federal government would get more
involved in these kinds of these kinds
of programs because like katy just said
it prevents large expenses
in other areas but it's going to take us
a while
to really build a system and really get
to the point where
we're saving those funds in other areas
so what do you think the future for the
federal
so i think we'll see more federal
participation for this we have
availed ourselves of many different
iterations of system of care grants
we have seen through our work with the
medicaid
federal medicaid office and building our
medicaid benefit for the fast forward
program
we're seeing their sort of hearts and
minds open a bit wider
around what uh needs to be invested in
by medicaid by the federal participation
for kids and families and not just
having a narrow
view of what um they would pay for so
we're seeing
them uh broaden their perspective on
what is necessary
to support these children families with
severe emotional disturbances
so i think you'll see in the future more
federal participation
than we've seen there is a huge push to
develop system of care
and again we've had about four different
system of care grants for new hampshire
to build upon what we've developed over
time
i think you'll see more uh broader sort
of assistance there
thank you you have a follow-up
uh no not right now thank you okay
uh anytime so um
who which state or states
are furthest ahead with implementing a
system of care
model and do they have demonstrable
results
to show that some of the
assumed benefits and the out years
erica says i know that we do have states
that we look to
and this will be another question
that will be really important for dcyf
director joe whitson to address it based
on his experience in new jersey
go ahead so our key partners
in the beginning of our system of care
wisconsin uh wraparound milwaukee was
our training partner they
trained us in uh system of care and high
fidelity wraparound
um and they have seen demonstral
uh returns on investments in the areas
of
children in dcyf either cps
or juvenile justice and a reduction in
acute hospitalizations for
folks with psychiatric concerns so
there's a real return on investment
there that is seen nationally and not
just in wisconsin
and we've also most recently because of
our
relationship with joe ribson now we have
partnered
with new jersey who has really turned
their system around
in in terms of right-sizing uh
children's behavioral health and and
their child protection
system so he has lots to offer
in terms of information his experience
in that system
and how he and i are working very
closely to
emulate that system we took a number of
legislators
down to new jersey so that they could
hear from
folks there um and he they had the
same uh experiences wrap around
milwaukee is
a real decrease in those court involved
kids either through cps or jj
and those receiving the right behavioral
health service at the right time
if i can just add in there too from the
previous presentation with new hampshire
hospital chair you had
brought up how do we serve more kids in
the community
and this is the system that serves those
kids in the community
this is what will bring down that wait
list which will
you know like the ceo of the hospital
mentioned there are always children who
will need
the hospitalization services but for
those that we can reach earlier
these this is the system that will do
that
so i'm trying to think i'll get to you
uh representative wallner in just a
second just
so in terms of demonstrating results i
kind of look at an
evolution of knowledge to go from
good theory good anecdotal information
experience based
to academic peer-reviewed
studies uh showing uh cost-benefit
analysis
to something that's even subjected to a
performance audit to where
results are are are tested by
consultants and
and and demonstrated to be uh
tangible so where where do you think
say new jersey or wisconsin is
and that sort of evolution of knowledge
so i would say wisconsin is about 20
some odd years
into their system evolution
new jersey is probably midway
in that evolution they're around 10 12
years
okay so my question was more
specifically how have they documented
their results
can can wisconsin give us something
that we could read and touch and look at
what what their
actual results are yes and actually
system of care is well documented
nationally as to what those return on
investments and outcomes ought to be
and we are on par with those and we can
certainly share the
national outcome uh literature with them
okay so i think based on where we're at
with the
status of our revenues come going into
the next two years
we really need to see something
that gives us confidence that this is
this is money well invested i'm not
saying it
isn't it's just new and
it's just relatively a lot of money real
to compared to what we have to look for
so um so if you could help us help you
that would be great representative
wallner
uh yes uh hi i am
i guess my question is
in 2020 we were only spending
and we were spending less than two
million dollars
here so so really
we are really at the infancy of building
this program
and we're just starting to
really get the program
up and ready so that we can start seeing
some of those results
and it seems like the future is that
we would see a lot fewer children at
needing hospitalization which is
probably one of the highest
cost programs that we have in our budget
is
a psychiatric hospital is probably one
of the highest cost
things that we do so it seems like this
is money well invested
in order to try to bring down some of
those
other high-cost programs
i i think we should maybe defer
an interactive conversation on this to
um are there any other uh questions
from the committee all right
[Music]
i would just ask when um this just get
discussed at
a working session that we make sure to
schedule
joe gripson to also join that discussion
we have a working session scheduled for
wednesday
and i suspect that mr ripple
can it's it's in our house calendar but
we can certainly
make sure mr winston knows i i don't
think i'll be able to have the directors
available for the meeting on wednesday
it conflicts with governor and council
for which they also need to attend
so i know that you have several working
sessions scheduled over the next couple
of weeks so hopefully we can
or maybe we could talk about it more on
friday and um
joe ribson's presentation and have erica
and katya join that conversation there
so so we as you pointed out we have
multiple working sessions
and the one on wednesday is our very
first one
and so i think
we're not going to be making anything
that feels like a decision
what we're going to be doing is learning
to
agree with one another about what kind
of
ways of working we're going to be doing
and what the major issues are we need to
look at
i i doubt if wednesday's
going to result in any sort of firm
budget decision
so i wouldn't worry about missing it is
what i'm trying to say
right i will be there i just know that
the directors will not be able to join
us wednesday
all right okay someone asked
go ahead sorry we can go okay
the last accounting unit is 2059 uh
which
is a grant that appears to be ending
during fiscal year 22
so there's not much to talk about on
so that is the last accounting unit in
that area there is still one more bureau
representative weiler raised his hand
yes sir uh thank you mr chair i had
a question while we had karen rounds
here that's that's not relevant to this
present but maybe she can give me a
quick answer i've got a meeting tomorrow
with my county commissioners
who are really upset over the state
uh increasing the cap 18 and taking 15
million dollars of state funds out of
the
money that used to go into that so it's
got to be picked up by the counties it's
going to cause a tax increase in the
counties it's
the biggest one we've had and so we're
wondering why that happened
so i think i that's not something i'm
prepared to speak about right now it's a
much longer conversation than just a few
minutes
we anticipate discussing that during the
division of long-term supports and
services budget which i believe is next
week
that's where that county cap
contribution
is is an accounting unit in that
division so it would be best to discuss
it then
uh when i also have the division
director available all right
quick answer when i see him tomorrow
thank you
okay i think we're ready to plunge on
does anyone need to break after that but
that felt rougher than most of them
you okay miss fox i'm fine
what i do want to ask is whether you
want to delve into the next
bureau with addressing
adult mental health services at this
point in time
we're prepared to do it but just want to
check in with you because
it may also take as long as this one it
may not have as many
um difficult um questions
yeah let me uh let me do a pull of the
committee i
i'm prone to wanting to go forward so
that you guys are
relieved of having to come back on
wednesday but
um representative walner your hand is up
do you do you have a question or do you
want to comment on whether we should
stop or continue
well it's 4 15 and i i i mean i think
we've been at it for a long time
i i i already have another meeting that
i'm supposed to be at it for so
um i do want to be here for this for
this presentation so
if we could wait for mond for wednesday
that would be great
for you ma'am we'll wait till wednesday
so well
it's really for katja more than it is
for me if she
if she can come back uh mr ripple can
can we work out a time for to finish
this bureau
i think sure i think whatever works for
the department you have the work session
scheduled for 9 30 as usual on wednesday
if if they're able to start at that time
you can start with that and then go into
a hospital to conversation or we can
start with house bill 2 and then finish
this i think it's really
we had we had planned it for 1 pm
because of governor and council
i have i have one contract on governor
and council but
um i believe that there's a presentation
at the beginning
of that um starting at 10 so i need to
wait that out
and i anticipate questions on that um
item
so so that's just a limitation
um and i don't see anybody being able to
cover council for me okay
then i think you could start with house
bill two in the morning and then resume
this at one pm
okay outstanding so representative
wallner do you have another question
no thank you thank you very much i
appreciate it
okay so so i i heard your request to
adjourn for the day um but i want to
um give representative nordgren a chance
to speak
thank you sir so we won't have
house bill 2 on by wednesday
a physical document probably or
well i don't think you'll i don't think
you'll have it in hard copy i do think
you'll have it because we just saw a
draft a couple hours ago
from ols and we all took a look at it
and let them know
if we had concerns and i think they're
if they haven't already they're about to
email it to representative wyler
so but when will we get a hard copy
a hard copy probably won't get until
okay did that answer your question
yes unfortunately yeah
all right so i don't want to adjourn
without allowing the attendees to raise
their hand
we've talked a lot here this afternoon
and there may be
some supplemental contra comments from
the public
so if you if you have uh something
germane to any of the things we talked
about or
you think will help us make some tough
decisions
i'm not seeing any so um oh wait
there's uh mr norton go ahead mr norton
you've introduced yourself already
let me just move him over yeah he
thank you mr chairman and and members of
the committee um and just in the
interest of
full transparency i want to let you know
that while nami new hampshire is not are
not treatment providers we do
participate
in the fast forward program providing
family peer support
but i just wanted to add a couple of
comments one that
um in the conversation one thing that
that i think is important that was left
out is that suicide's the second leading
cause of death for our youth
ages 10 through 34 and um and young
adults and
um and we've seen pre-covered
the uh it's well documented the rise in
anxiety and depression among
our youth and young adults and it's
gotten considerably worse during covid
so i just think that that's an important
consideration as we're looking at
um at things moving forward and then you
know it's at some point
um perhaps when there's more of a
conversation about mobile crisis
response
but to representative weiler's question
about how to pay for this
there is the federal suicide prevention
hotline act which was signed by
president trump in october
to create a three-digit 988
suicide prevention number which by by
everyone's agreement is going to become
a mental health crisis number
and um and that does allow for charging
a telecom
surcharge to pay for crisis response
services i know people may not
like that idea but that currently the 75
cents we charge for every telecom bill
in in new hampshire right now is paying
for
raising about 14 million dollars in
funds that pays for 911
in our state so um just something to
consider
and that that will be implemented
nationally
in uh in july of 2022
so we need to be thinking about how all
that
how all of what's been spelled out with
mobile crisis and system of care
folds into a crisis um response
so i'm taking your comment to part b
potentially part of the answer to the
question that got left open
about how we would find a um
a central um oh god what's the word
the words just escape me the the person
you call in who distributes the
the calls the central call center
um that that this 988 answer may be
uh a potential solution to the question
of how we're going to come up with a
well it certainly fits into yes that
overall the
the central hub that the state is i'm
stepping forward
and it will tie into 911 as well as
2-1-1 in terms of the doorway
and probably katya or someone else could
explain a little bit more that
as they mentioned before that the rfp
the request for proposal announcement
relative to who is going to get that
contract is due to come out relatively
soon and there would be more details
about that presumably when that contract
is announced
so so let's let's roll that into the
wednesday conversation miss fox if
you care to address it then that'll give
all right um anything else uh
i see uh representative nordgren go
ahead
thank you very much um
maybe we can include this discussion
on wednesday um many of you
don't know but there's this group called
headrest here in the upper valley
and that's a suicide prevention hotline
they cover new hampshire even part of
maine
and vermont and so maybe katja can dress
how that fits into the whole system i
didn't bring it up today
because i wasn't sure this is the right
time so maybe you can
flash that out a little bit on wednesday
we will be prepared to do that which was
part of our slide deck
um as you can see but we'll make sure
that we address it specifically
yeah they got money in the last budget i
think as a footnote
200 000 each year but i'm
unsure if they got the money or if
i we haven't kept i had kevin searching
to see
if it was included this budget but i
don't
think having seen it so maybe we could
update that sure i can just say yes they
got the money and yes it's in the budget
and i would just add representative
nordgren and yes they are the
certified crisis call center for the
state that the 988 number would be
directed toward
at this point in time yeah
okay any other questions from the
committee
okay thank you mr norton and then uh
last call for
the attendees to raise a hand if they
have something they
you know it can take a second to find
okay uh we're gonna be back wednesday
afternoon so if i if we adjourn without
you finding the button
you can try again on wednesday so
um uh i think we're at the point where
we can adjourn
is are there anyone opposed adjourning
at this moment
okay well hey thank you it's been a very
long day thank you mr ripple thank you
everyone from dhhs i really appreciate
it